Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Sorry, I decided to loop because, like, I'm very tired.
Toki is dizzle.
What's new, Toki?
That's my secret.
I'm always tired.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
So thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
But yes, hello, everybody.
I am on Twitch today because we have a sponsor today.
On Twitch.
And this is, like, the sponsor waiting room right now because I cannot say what it is until 30 minutes.
I can say what it is in 30 minutes.
That's basically it.
It might have leaked earlier because I might have messed up a little.
But you guys didn't see.
If you guys were here camping in my chat, you didn't see what it was.
I turned it off the moment I realized I might have made an oopsie.
But that's okay.
We didn't see.
It didn't happen on stream.
No leaks, guys.
No leaks.
I sound sick because I am sick.
I feel my brain feels a little foggy today because I am still sick.
I've been, like, blowing my nose all day.
Today was not, like, the best day last night because I was coughing myself.
I was coughing a lot last night.
Well, not a lot.
Like, I mean, it's not as much as I used to cough when I am...
When I do get, like, really, really sick.
But I did cough a bit.
But, like, you know, I'm not coughing now.
I'm gonna...
And then I'm gonna start coughing later.
Uh, but it was not as bad as it should be, which is nice.
Um, but I do sound like, you know, I sound terrible.
I know.
I'm sorry.
Uh, I need to warm up my voice.
The moment my voice is more warmed up, um, things will sound a lot better.
Uh, Nestrix and Poofy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Um, but yes, my brain does feel just a little bit foggy today.
Um, just because, like, uh, I'm definitely gonna head to bed after this stream.
Uh, I did sleep really early yesterday.
But, I mean, I did have, like, three hours of sleep yesterday.
Uh, due to circumstances.
And I woke up today.
I woke up today at...
I wish I had those headphones where, like, I could just, like, walk anywhere.
And you could still hear me.
And I could literally just, like, stream from my bed.
I...
Like, you know, doing a sick stream, and I'll just be streaming from my bed.
And I'll just have to pull up my own stream on my phone just to make sure nothing crazy is happening while I'm in my bed.
But sadly, I do not have that privilege right now.
But, oh my gosh, sorry, my brain blanked up because of how I'm not okay.
What was I going to say?
Anyway, dad update!
I'll give you guys a dad update.
I know you guys love dad updates.
He is at the dog sitter right now.
And he's having a good time.
Apparently, he is being fed wet food right now, which is why he's extra happy.
Because usually we give him, you know, dog kibble.
So, because he is a sick boy, we decided to give him some wet food.
And he's been devouring that, apparently.
So, I'll give you guys a little cute update.
The dog sitter sent me, like, a little text about how he's doing.
So, alright.
So, here's a little dog update.
I'm working from... this is from the dog sitter.
I'm working from home today, and Doki wants to sit up at my desk with me.
So, I rigged this.
He's quite happy with it.
And apparently, he was also on the patio sunbathing.
So, there's a little cute dad update.
He's just... he... basically, this is where he lives right now.
Because he's not allowed to move at the moment.
So, he lives in this little... in this little box thing.
So, they, like, basically, like, bring this box thing everywhere with him.
Because he's not allowed to move around a lot.
So, this is, like, where he lives for now.
Until he's able to walk better.
Until he's able to walk more.
And stuff.
So, yeah.
And apparently, all he does is sleep.
Which is nice.
Because, you know, sleeping is really good for recovery.
And then he still does this, like, you know, physical therapy exercises.
And stuff like that.
But this is where he lives for now.
He's, like, he's, like, a little...
A little fish in a fishbowl.
But he's happy.
And that's all that matters.
Dad of the box.
What is your wisdom today?
Uh, man.
That's the little dad update that we have for all of you guys.
Yeah.
My little package weenie.
Oh, my God.
I can feel how sick I am right now.
I don't know how.
But somehow, I always manage to have my sponsor streams right when I'm sick.
Which is very unlucky.
Either I'm sick during, like, conventions.
Or I'm sick during sponsors.
Uh, my body has not been doing so well.
Um, contained for his crimes.
Uh, I am cursed.
You know?
Okay.
So, I'm starting to believe this little, like, thing that showed up on my Twitter feed one day.
Where you were supposed to calculate your luck or whatever for the new year.
And they're like, oh, find your, like, find your month.
And what was it?
It was like, find your month.
Like, your birth month.
And your birth, uh, birth date.
And, like, see how lucky you are for the new year.
And then, I found my number.
And it was at the very end.
Like, I was at the, one of the ends of how, of the unlucky meter.
And I was like, oh, that can't be true.
And now I'm like, oh, maybe it is true.
Maybe.
Oh, man.
I don't know.
Now I'm worried.
Maybe they were on this.
It's just like astrology.
Maybe astrology was real this entire time.
Who would have thought?
Also, the Apex Legend.
Thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
And thank you for the tier one sub.
Charlie, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, my God.
Maybe they're right.
If that's real, what else could also be real?
Oh, my God.
Maybe astrology was real all along.
I knew it.
I knew my... my stars.
I won't say it.
I don't remember how... Astrology is like based off of... Oh, cool.
I got a little frog.
Look at my little frog, guys.
Choo-choo.
Look at him go.
Oh my god, I got a little frog.
Sorry, my brain is much more... Like, I don't have ADHD, guys.
But it's much more ADHD than usual.
But I don't have ADHD.
At least don't become a star.
But the stars!
The stars are trying to tell me something!
Oh yeah.
I didn't hope my schedule will be posted later tonight.
When I wake up.
Because like, obviously after the stream, I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna be like...
But...
Oh my god, what was I gonna say?
Oh yeah, my schedule.
So, my schedule.
There's not gonna be anything much new in my schedule.
Other than like, you know, finishing some series.
So like, you know, Dynasty Warriors.
And everything.
So, I was just waiting for confirmation on like, times for stuff.
But, uh, but other than that, there's not gonna be like, a lot of new stuff on my schedule.
Other than what I've already told you guys.
Other than like, the stuff I want to finish and everything.
The one thing I do want to...
No collapse this week.
I need to take a break.
Um, at the moment.
Because, you know, um...
I'm tired.
There's a lot of stuff to finish as well.
Um, there's Dynasty Warriors that we have to finish as well.
And there's a lot of reading and everything.
So, no collapse this week.
I mean, we did finish our Ford Park series with Mint earlier.
With, um, with Visage.
So, uh, so we're just chillin' today.
Um, and everything.
Um, I'm trying to see if there's anything else.
You know, I can't wait to finally finish Dynasty Warriors.
So I can start Epic Mickey.
I really want to...
I'm actually really, really, really looking forward to finishing...
To starting Epic Mickey.
Because that's a game that I've been wanting to play for the longest time.
And, uh, it seems like, um, it seems really fun.
And I know it's a platformer.
But it's different, you know?
Um, I'm tired of trying...
Okay, okay.
I've been playing a lot of really difficult games lately.
Okay, guys?
And I am tired of trying.
I want something.
I want something more chill.
I'm tired of games.
And fucking becoming souls-like out of nowhere.
I...
I want...
I want a baby game.
Sometimes a gamer wants to stop gaming, okay?
Sometimes a gamer just wants to...
Just wants to chill.
All right?
And today...
And this next week is that week.
Look, I had to deal with hit and run.
I have to deal with reading.
I have to deal with...
Dynasty Warriors suddenly becoming souls-like.
We're at the fight Lu Bu.
And then be stuck there for almost two hours.
And I'm tired.
I'm...
I'm so tired.
I'm tired of crashing out.
I need my weenie hut junior.
I...
I want to be in the weenie hut junior.
I'm tired of this grandpa.
I...
I want...
I want to be in the clouds.
I...
I need the super weenie hut junior.
Just don't cry.
Oh, that's going to make me cry.
That's too damn bad.
Anyway, I can't wait for next week where I can be in the super weenie hut junior and relax just like how my boy dad is relaxing right now in his little box.
I...
I want to be in my transparent box.
When can I be in my transparent box, grandpa?
Wait...
My box of comfort.
Um...
Yes, that's why I said next week is when things get to be chill.
Because I'll be finishing a bunch of other stuff this week.
Um...
So I can finally chill next week.
And then I realize...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so I'm going to put...
Most likely I'm going to put Super Mario Man at a later time.
Uh...
Just because like, you know...
Um...
It's a lot of reading and my voice is not ready for a lot of reading right now.
I sound like I am just about to hit be reading.
Sorry.
I sound like I'm...
I'm hitting puberty right now.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
For real.
Um...
So we're putting...
And there's a lot of reading.
Uh...
So...
Um...
We're going to put that at the end of the week so I can relax a little bit.
Tomorrow there's no stream.
I'll let you guys know right now.
There's going to be no stream tomorrow.
Because, um...
Like, you know...
Yesterday I had a stream.
Today I have a stream.
And usually...
Usually Sunday and Monday are like my rest days.
But...
You know...
I had obligations.
So...
Tomorrow...
Um...
There is no streams.
No streams.
Also I found out who...
Who the heck that guy was.
Um...
Also you guys really don't know.
I'm trying not to swear because I'm trying to put my mental barriers up.
It takes a while to like rev up the engine for the mental barriers that I am doing a sponsor stream.
So I'm trying not to swear right now.
Just so like...
The barrier's up before I go straight into the sponsor.
Like...
As you know...
A lot of them are always like no profanity.
I'm like...
Gosh darn it.
Oh man.
Gosh...
Gosh darn it.
Don't put the Lord's name in vain.
Um...
No...
Yeah.
No hecking swears.
Oh frick.
Anyway.
Uh...
Where was I?
Okay.
So yesterday...
You guys didn't watch yesterday's stream where I had to deal with some movement players yesterday.
I finally...
I found out who it was that was trying to do those gosh darn tap strafes on me.
Um...
And then I shot him down with some shotguns.
It was actually...
It was Bullet.
For those who don't know Bullet is a pro player um...
in pro league.
So I was like I knew it.
I knew you were someone.
by...
by killing...
Also...
but that means by killing a pro that means I'm just as good as a pro player.
Guys.
I am...
Hahahaha!
That means I am just as good!
Woo!
Hahahaha!
Yes, that is how it works, guys!
Everyone knows that's how it works when you kill a pro player.
You, you, you absorb their skills and you become them.
A dev, a pred, and a pro.
Let's go!
Um, also, what's funny, um, was that when we posted that tweet, and I was like, real?
People actually thought I was, I got hired as a dev?
Hahahaha!
Congratulations!
And, and I don't have a, and you know what?
I won't say I'm not.
Hahahaha!
Because it's on them for not wanting.
watching VODs.
Hahahaha!
It's, it's on them for not watching streams.
So it is not my duty, uh, to correct them.
Hahahaha!
Exactly!
Um, I'm, I'm like, okay, I'm like, if you guys are wondering what's going on, I'm like lying back on my chair, Right now, my head is up in the ceiling, and I am enjoying life before I'm back in the grind.
I'm... I'm... I'm... I'm... I'm peak comfy right now.
Ah... Today is just comfy chatting before we're thrown back into the... to the cog wheel.
Until... Until... Back... Back in peace for now.
Um... Other life... There's not really much life updates.
I mean, nothing really much was happening the last couple of days.
Oh, yeah.
I was watching Ink Masters, um... Recently.
Um... I was watching... Actually... Well, that's a lie.
I was watching clips of Ink Masters, because I got... Um...
It was a short that showed up about, like, how... Okay, so they called the people...
Okay, for those who don't know, um... What Ink Masters is, it is a tattoo reality show.
So, it's basically, you know, how, like, you know, America's Next Top Model is basically, like, America's Next Top Tattoo Artist type deal, but they're called Ink Masters.
So, I was watching shorts of, like, parodies.
Like, a par... Okay, so a parody of, like, Ink Masters showed up.
And it was basically, like, the person they were tattooing was talking about how they wanted all of this stuff for the competition.
And then, like, they went, like, I want this, I want this, I want this, I want this.
And then the guy was like, that's not possible.
And then the person who was getting tattooed was like, I don't care.
Like, I want this.
And then the tattoo artist was like, yeah, but I can...
You're gonna get a really bad tattoo then.
And then I'll get eliminated.
And then... By the way, they call themselves canvases, by the way.
The people were getting their self-tattooed.
They're called canvases.
Canvases.
And then the canvas was like, you know, they dehumanizes them, which is nice.
Anyway, the canvases were like, I don't care.
And in the comment section, they were like, I thought this was an over-exaggeration.
But the first clip I saw literally had that guy.
Like, it had an example of that type of canvas.
And...
Anyway, so that led me...
I was like, wait, this is legit?
Like, he wasn't over-exaggerating in this parody?
So then it just led me to the rabbit hole of, like, Ink Master clips.
And then I just couldn't stop watching for, like, an hour or two of just Ink Master stuff.
Um, and it's so interesting because it's like, I think the canvases, it's really interesting for the canvases because, like, to be able to get, like, you know, a permanent tattoo on your body.
I mean, I guess you could do, like, laser removal and stuff like that.
But to get, like, a permanent tattoo on a competition reality show and, like, still have the ego to demand things is, like, crazy.
It's wild to me.
Because I'm, like, bro, you are on...
They have, like...
They're on a time limit, too.
And, like, so there's, like, a time limit and stuff.
So, like, the...
The mindset of, like, a canvas to be, like, I want all of this within...
Within this time limit.
And then, like, so...
And then, like, if you demand too much because you're supposed to explain what you want during the competition.
And then, like...
So, like, before you get assigned to a...
Before you get assigned to a tattoo artist, you have to say what you want in front of all of them.
And then the winner...
The winner of the previous challenge will give three of the...
Like, two to three of the canvases a skull to signify a death skull.
So, like, if the winner, like, hates...
Like, wants a particular tattoo artist to win...
To lose.
Sorry.
They give, like, the hardest canvases, like, a death skull.
And if they get a death skull, they're, like, assigned to, like, one...
To tattoo artists they want to lose.
And then, so, like...
I'm like, that must suck for the canvas.
Because they're, like...
It basically tells them when you're handed the death skull, you're, like...
You are unreasonable.
In front of everyone.
Like, in front of, like, the whole world.
It's like, you are unreasonable.
You have a shit idea.
Yeah.
I was like...
And then...
But the thing is, some of them would, like, continue to want to still get that tattoo as well.
So, it's like...
Despite being, like, you know, aired out to, like, all the whole world.
That, like, you are an unreasonable client.
They're like, I still want this tattoo.
I was like...
And then...
Yeah.
And, like...
And then, like, not only would they have, like, really bad ideas...
Really bad ideas.
Another one is that they would get, like, tattoos in, like...
Okay, so, like, apparently one of those, like, I want to...
Like, one of the challenges was, like...
Um...
One of the challenges was, like, I want to get a tattoo on my sternum.
So, for those who don't know what sternums are...
Like, where the sternum is...
It's, like, below your chest.
And, like, where your ribs are.
And, apparently, it's, like, the most painful area to ever get a tattoo on.
So, like, if you ever get a tattoo on a sternum, you...
It's the most...
The worst idea you can have because it's so painful.
And then...
The canvas that got the death skull was, like...
Oh, the longest I could sit was two hours before...
And then...
Before I had to give up.
And I'm like, why are you here?
And then she's like...
So, on my sternum...
I was just like...
Why is she here?
Obviously, she got the death skull.
You did not...
I was like, bro...
Like, if you are really bad with pain...
Maybe, like, do it outside of a reality show?
Because, like...
Apparently, you get free tattoos, basically.
Like, the whole reason...
Some of these canvases...
I like how I'm dehumanizing them, too.
Because I don't even, like...
I just call them canvases now.
But it's just so much easier.
But the whole point of it is that it's a free tattoo.
If you get picked.
But still...
Like...
You can get a really bad free tattoo.
And, like...
There was one...
Oh, my God.
I was watching a clip.
And...
Oh, wait.
It's 4...
4.30.
All right.
But to the surprise of...
Now...
No one.
I don't know.
So...
But, uh...
It is...
4.30.
So, that means I can reveal...
What?
Oh, my gosh.
It is...
Overwatch!
Yay!
Sorry.
Let me explain.
Yes!
Yippee!
Yeah!
Everyone!
Yes!
I have been sponsored by Overwatch 2.
Or Overwatch.
Um...
To check out the newest updates for the new season.
Let me turn on...
So, what leaked was I had a timer on.
And it, like...
Accidentally, when I was put...
When I was setting up the...
The notifications and everything for this.
Um...
It, like, automatically made...
It automatically made...
It automatically updated...
So, it leaked out...
Instantly...
That this was my sponsor.
It auto-update.
There it is!
That's the one I was talking about!
The stadium is open!
Yes!
Anyway...
So...
Let me pin this on, too.
Yes!
Alright!
But, yes...
It is really cool to say that I got sponsored by Blizzard and Overwatch to check out the newest update.
I haven't played Overwatch in a while, so I didn't even check out Stadium.
So a lot of this is going to be incredibly new to me, just because it has been a while since I've played Overwatch.
And it's actually crazy to say that I am sponsored by Overwatch, because this is really how I got started streaming in general.
My very first stream was an Overwatch stream.
And so it's crazy to say that I made it at this point in my career as an indie to be able to be sponsored by them.
So yes, let me tweet it out real quick on Twitch today.
Alright, right now.
Alright, boom.
Alright, there you go.
So yeah, it's like we came full circle.
But let me adjust all my Twitch stuff so people will know what it is.
This is the hard part of announcing it during stream, because now I have to like...
Please, I am... I have been streaming for at least four years, guys.
I'm... Please, I... Be gentle.
Guys, professional streamer here.
I need to... I need to do all of this now.
Alright, let's see.
I need to make sure what the title is correct and everything.
Alright.
Oh yeah, and then we have drops, by the way.
Yay, drops.
Okay.
Drops.
Check mark emoji.
I think I should have... I should have definitely...
Um...
I should have definitely, like, had the thing pre-written.
Instead of...
Um...
Instead of writing it live.
But it's okay.
We're learning.
Drops.
Yeah, not now, though.
Not now.
We're not at the category.
Watch the...
See...
Checking out...
Checking out stadium.
And then...
Hashtag...
Hashtag ad, I believe.
Oh yeah!
Overwatch partner.
And then hashtag ad.
Yay!
So I won't get in trouble.
With the FTC.
Yippee!
So y'all know it's an ad.
Ha ha ha ha.
Um...
But yeah, it is...
Quite surreal to be sponsored.
Um...
By Overwatch.
Like I said...
Um...
This is, like, a full circle for me.
If you ever check my...
I guess, like, my Twitch tracker...
You see...
How many hours I have streamed Overwatch...
During...
On...
On Twitch alone.
Um...
And now...
I get paid to play Overwatch!
Let's go!
Ha ha ha ha!
Um...
Anyway...
Back to the Ink Master story.
Because we're not starting yet, by the way.
Uh...
Back to Ink Masters.
Um...
Okay.
Where was I?
Oh yeah.
So...
I was watching one particular clip.
And...
Uh...
One of the clips was talking about how the tattoo was gonna be on the face.
So...
Obviously, everyone was like...
Oh my god.
Face tattoos.
Cause it's obviously, like, you know...
The...
One of the most sensitive areas...
Of everything.
And, like, how...
How, like...
How much, like, potential it can go wrong.
Especially on the face.
And then, so, like...
One of the guy...
That wanted a...
Tattoo on the...
On the face.
Slash head.
By the way, it's, like, all parts of the head.
So, like...
It can go all the way to the side of the head and everything.
And...
Um...
So...
The guy was like...
I want a Grim Reaper...
Riding a metal horse.
And, um...
Having a long sword...
That goes all the way here.
And I want the horse to be metallic.
And I...
And I was like...
Bro, it's on a face.
Yeah!
Obviously, guess who got the death skull?
I...
I wonder...
Who got the death skull in that challenge?
Um...
And...
With time constraints, too.
With time constraints.
And...
Bro, just do a tear or something.
And then...
Obviously, the tattoo artist was like...
We're not doing that.
And then he was like...
Okay, he's like...
Choose one thing.
And then the canvas was like...
Okay, I want a metallic horse.
And then the tattoo artist was like...
No!
Look at the sick Grim Reaper I sketched out.
Like, doesn't this Grim Reaper look so cool?
And so, um, so, and the canvas was like, but I, but, like, I sort of really wanted the metallic horse.
And then the tattoo artist was like, we don't have time for that.
But also, uh, crew, thank you for the tier 1 stuff.
Thank you.
Anyway, so it was really funny because the guy, like, he was like, okay, so the tattoo artist was like, obviously, he was like an old veteran.
He's like, he's been in the business for, like, 20 plus years.
And he was like, he was like, he was like, I am not taking any, I am not letting this one guy ruin my chances.
I, I will convince him to not do the metallic horse.
Oh, yeah.
And then, so, yeah, it looked really cool though.
It looked really cool when they went with the tattoo, like, when we went with the Grim Reaper.
Like, I was gonna say, like, how, how the heck are you gonna do, like, a metallic horse?
The Grim Reaper with a giant-ass sword riding a metallic horse on the face.
I was like, how would all of that fit on the goddamn head slash face?
And, I was like, thank God they swapped, changed it.
Um, um, anyway, anyway, so, uh, um, another thing on that show, there was one where, uh, oh my god.
There was one where, oh my god, I'm trying to remember exactly what it was.
Oh, yeah, it was for the sternum.
And, obviously, it's super painful.
Oh my god, I'm trying to say, what was it called?
The mandala?
Mandala?
Okay, so, one of the person wanted a mandala on the sternum.
And, obviously, like, yeah, so they wanted, it's like a type of flower, I believe.
Yeah, it's a, it's like a type of, like, flower design.
Um, so they wanted a mandala flower on the sternum.
Um, and then the tattoo artist was like, the mandala is, obviously, she got the death skull.
And, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah A rose tattoo.
Same, but yeah.
So, oh man, not as cliche or common.
How is that?
It's because he didn't want to do a mandala.
Because, like, the mandala is, like, really difficult to do on the sternum.
Because it's a lot of details.
It's literally speech a thousand.
But then the rose would be easier to tattoo.
Like... I thought that was so funny.
They're like, yeah, like, we should do a rose.
It's less common than a mandala.
I thought that was... I thought that was really funny.
Anyway, you guys should check out Ink Masters.
Not sponsored by Ink Masters, by the way.
I... I just... So you guys know, I am not sponsored by Ink Masters.
I just thought it was very...
It was... It was a very enjoy... Like, I was even... I was just watching clips, too.
But it was very enjoyable.
So, um... I would highly suggest... It's actually, like, good... Like, good time... Like, good time... Way to kill time.
Um... Even though I shouldn't be procrastinating yesterday.
I used to watch it, but I got tired of all the drama.
I mean, it's a reality show.
It's a... It's a reality show.
So, like, obviously, they have to, like, make sure, um...
There's drama and everything.
Just so it makes people watch.
But honestly, you can just consume the clips.
The clips were just... Worked just as well as the normal drama.
Like, the clips work just as well to, like, watch in general.
There's one compilation where it was, like, the worst tattoos ever received.
And... In Ink Masters.
And I'm like, man, it must really suck to be that one of the canvases featured in...
In... In that... In that clip compilation.
Because I'm wondering...
Do they, like, get free laser tattoo removal then?
Like...
Like, if, you know, you got one of the worst ones...
Do they get free tattoo laser removal?
I paid for it by the show?
Because it's, like...
Like...
I guess it might be your fault if you were one of the death skulls.
Oh, yeah.
I remember there was one version where he...
They were like, I want a tattoo of my dead spouse.
But I want it all in green.
And I was like, what?
I was like...
They wanted a portrait of their dead spouse on their leg.
But green.
I'm like, what?
So he could look like Shrek?
Like...
I was like...
Why green?
It was like monochromatic tattoo.
Like...
Yeah, but it was all in green.
So I was like...
What?
Is it going to look like Shrek or something?
And then the tattoo artist was obviously like...
What?
How about we don't do green?
What if we do red?
I was like...
Like what?
Like a...
Ghostbuster...
Slime ghost or something?
I think it's not...
It's not going to glow in the dark.
Exactly.
It's not going to glow in the dark or something.
Also, I forgot to mention.
If you see the title, it's exclamation point Overwatch.
So you use the exclamation point Overwatch to bring up the command for the sponsor.
Yeah.
Also, by the way...
Sorry.
This is like a little...
You cannot skip this ad, by the way.
Anyway, there is a cool down for it.
But what I was going to say was that if you click on the link, it really does help out a lot and support the stream.
Sorry.
Look, I had to watch YouTube with ads, okay?
So...
This is...
You know, it's like...
This is my YouTube ad insert.
For you...
In the middle of the video, you just get a random ad on your mobile phone.
That's me.
This is the stream.
If I had to watch...
Watch the compilation with ads.
I...
I'm giving you my own ad for my recap.
Just because you get...
Don't think you get a free recap, guys.
Don't...
Don't think that.
All right.
I think like...
Okay.
So, for like the...
Um...
For like the...
Uh...
Overwatch...
Overwatch 2.
Uh...
In like 15 minutes.
Um...
I need you guys to know.
It has been...
The last time I touched Overwatch was before Stadium was released.
Which...
I mean, it wasn't that long ago.
But like...
Even before then.
It was like a couple of months.
Um...
So...
I know they have a new hero.
And the new hero is like...
Um...
It's like basically like...
Like she uses...
I believe in...
Uh...
Crossbow.
And...
Oh my gosh.
There's like a lot of new stuff about it.
I'm trying to like...
Remember on top of my head.
Uh...
But...
There's like a lot of new skins.
A lot of new...
The thing I do like about Overwatch...
Is that...
The skin collaborations...
Is very...
Is really interesting.
Cause...
They have...
A lot of...
Really cool skin collaborations.
And I heard that...
The newest skin collaborations they're doing...
Is...
Uh...
Gundam.
For their anniversary.
And they gave Mercy...
They gave Mercy...
The main Gundam skin.
I...
I thought that was...
I thought that was funny.
I thought it was funny that Mercy was the new Gundam.
Gundam.
There's obviously other characters, but they gave... Yeah, they gave her as she... Exactly.
As she deserves, okay?
You know, the classic one.
The classic Gundam.
I want to pilot her.
Prom Queen, thank you for that tier one sub.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, is it Gundam?
Yeah.
So, there's also other collaborations and everything.
And then, you know what's funny?
I was looking on Twitter.
And someone was like, oh man.
Because they announced Doki Watch, I thought they were doing a sponsored collaboration with Doki.
Well then!
Yes, they are!
So for those who don't know.
Well, well, well.
Look what we have here.
Doki Watch is real.
Little do they know.
They are sponsoring me.
Well, well, well.
So for those who don't know what Doki Watch is, it's basically...
It's like their whole... They're doing a magical girl, like, collaborate... Not collaboration, sorry.
It's like their own thing.
They're doing a magical girl, like, arc in Overwatch.
So there's, like, magical girl skins.
And, um, a bunch of magical girl cosmetics right now for Doki Watch.
And...
And there's also, like, I believe they're doing, like, some...
Um, like, some little, like, storyline that they're doing on Twitter as well as social media.
From what I've seen.
But yes!
Mahou Shoujo!
Yes!
There's, uh, magical girl outfits right now in Overwatch too.
Um, so yeah, we're gonna look at those as well.
That's why it's called Doki Watch.
Cause, like, Doki Doki.
And then, yeah!
That's why, yeah, so...
Uh, so that's why they're doing a little...
They called it Doki Watch.
And I thought it was really...
By the way...
When Doki Watch was first announced, like, there was nothing regarding me collab...
Like, being sponsored by Overwatch.
So, like, it was nice to find out that I was...
I was gonna be sponsored by Overwatch later.
And I was like, oh, the timing was so perfect.
You know, since, you know, I'm Doki.
And I'm gonna be talking about Doki Watch.
It was... Yeah, it was perfect timing too.
My first Overwatch sponsor, um, um, as Doki.
Uh, well, technically, it's not my first first Overwatch sponsor but like...
You know, my first Overwatch sponsor as Doki.
Um, and, um, the prophecy has been fulfilled.
Uh, so full circle, yeah.
Um, it was nice.
It's just nice to...
You know, just another thing to check off my little list of stuff.
Um, that I really wanted to accomplish as Doki.
So, I'm really happy about that.
Um, what else?
What else can I do for... for, uh... uh... life update?
Oh yeah, you know what's funny?
I saw that... I saw that, uh...
I saw that Gordon Ramsay brought Hell's Kitchen to Roblox.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay, Roblox has had some... really... lots of insane collaboration recently.
I don't know if you guys noticed it.
Yeah, so... so not only was there like...
Oh yeah, by the way, I've like saved... wait, do I still have that Twitter account?
I know I like saved it on my... I saved it on my, uh...
Well, I didn't save it, but like, I have it on my browser.
And I've been keeping it on my browser just to be like, remember this.
Remember to check back on my end to make sure...
Oh, yeah.
The end.
So, I've been... Remember when I told you guys about...
Wait, is it out yet?
Enter... Oh, my God.
The end is out now.
Oh, my God.
Okay, guys.
I've always wanted to, like...
I've wanted to check out the end for Roblox.
Because it's like... Okay, so for those who don't know, this game...
This...
This game is made by the developers...
By the creators of Chainsaw Man.
And what was it?
I forgot.
It was Chainsaw Man and something else.
I don't remember who...
The director.
Yeah, it was made by the director of Chainsaw Man.
And what was the other one?
He did other stuff, too.
But that was, like, one of the biggest things.
And the...
And I was waiting for this game to come out for the longest time.
Because they have, like, actual, like...
Famous...
Uh...
Japanese voice actors.
So...
One of the Japanese voice actors they got...
Was the one who voice-act...
Nezuko...
In Demon Slayer.
So they...
And then the other one...
Was the one who did Bochi from Bochi Rock.
And...
Yeah!
So I'm like...
I was like...
This is a Roblox game, sir.
They...
What is this cast?
Yes!
So I've been, like...
Um...
Yeah!
They've been...
Getting, like...
Actual, like...
Top tier voice actors.
Or voice actresses.
And...
Um...
And, like...
Obviously, the creative Chainsaw.
Like...
Oh!
And JJK, too.
Oh, yeah!
They did JJK and...
And...
Chainsaw Man.
Like, the director for it.
Um...
So, yeah!
So I've been really curious...
How this game is gonna be...
Because it's, like...
How...
You know...
It's Roblox!
But...
I also heard...
That they're also going really...
Hard...
Like, on VTubers in general.
On...
Especially on JP's side.
Because...
Uh...
Because, apparently, from what I'm told...
Roblox's popularity in Japan...
Is skyrocketing.
So...
Obviously...
Because, you know...
Whenever a game gets really, really popular in Japan...
Companies go hard.
You know?
So, like...
Um...
I know they, like...
They're starting to collaborate...
With a lot of...
They're trying to...
They're starting to collaborate with VTubers right now...
For...
For Roblox and stuff...
On...
In Japan.
So, I thought that was really interesting.
So, now I notice why...
The...
Why...
They're making the end...
Right now...
Yeah...
It's my time...
Ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha...
Yeah...
Official Roblox X VTuber collabs...
Are starting to...
On the rise right now in Japan.
So, that's why we have...
Literally...
The...
The development for...
The end was...
That went crazy hard.
Ha ha ha...
That's a crazy sentence to say.
Hey, I don't make the rules here.
Ha ha ha...
All right.
Let me go.
Since it's almost time...
Let me set up...
My stream real quick for this.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba.
All right.
Yeah.
Here I am.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
That's me.
Ha ha ha.
Hello.
It's me, Dookie.
Hello, everybody.
All right.
Oops.
That's not it.
Ha ha ha.
Oops.
Sorry.
It was just for three seconds.
Guys, it was just for three seconds.
I...
Ha ha ha.
Oh my...
Sorry.
I got this.
Professional.
I've been streaming for at least four years.
All right.
Ha ha ha.
Let's see.
Let me put this here.
I don't know what it covers because it's been a while since I've, uh, I booted up.
Guys, it's not five yet.
I still have time.
I can make little mistakes before it hits 5 p.m.
Guys.
I...
I can...
I can make small mistakes before it hits 5.
I...
Five more minutes.
All right.
Let me blow my nose real quick and stay hydrated first, guys.
Category has yet to be changed, guys.
I still have time.
I haven't changed the category yet.
Guys.
I was talking about Roblox earlier, chat.
Oh, yeah.
I might need Soundguy's help for this because I haven't done an Overwatch stream in a long time.
So, I don't know what the sound would be.
Let me double check.
Let me double streaming on...
Oh, I do.
Never mind.
JK, Soundguy, I don't need you no more.
JK, I didn't mean that, Soundguy.
Please.
You did a great job.
I didn't mean that, Soundguy.
I swear.
I bet he wasn't even here to hear that anyway, so it's okay.
It's okay.
I have a record.
I found out I did have a record of...
Of Overwatch for it.
Oh, wait.
They have hero bands now.
Bands.
Oh, wait.
I forgot they have hero bands.
Oh, what's funny?
Is that people are now, like, like, even when you...
Okay, so, like, they got their streamer mode.
Because, like, there's hero bands now.
And then, I know some people are gonna, like, remember...
Are gonna start to remember, like, names and stuff.
And levels and stuff.
Who are you looking forward to banning?
I can't say, because it's pretty negative.
I can't...
I'm trying to be positive here.
Some people in chat are correct.
Some people...
See, I'm not the one being toxic here.
Okay?
It's not me.
That's being toxic.
Oh, man.
Oh, yes.
I know about the perk system.
I've actually...
I've, like, played a bit of Overwatch when the perk systems were first introduced.
And they were all, like, really interesting.
I know, like, some of you guys might not have been on Overwatch in a long time.
Yeah, some of you guys are like, there's a perk system now?
Yes, I know.
So, but when I heard about the perk system, I went in to check it out myself.
Because, you know, obviously, like, I was like, there's a perk system?
So, it's actually really interesting.
I'll show some of the perk system for you guys.
Because I know some of you guys have not seen it before.
So, you know what?
I think it's time.
I'll start a little early.
I think it's all right.
All right.
Overwatch.
Overwatch 2.
All right.
Let me make sure.
I have everything here.
All right.
Battle.net.
Guys, I even updated my game before I started my stream.
That's how you know I'm being very professional.
All right.
Back to my roots.
Whoops.
Dookie, why?
Because I forgot to do this.
Back to my roots.
Get in here, everyone.
We're back to my origin.
It's Dookie from four years ago.
Or five years ago.
All right.
So, look at that.
Oh, wait.
You guys can't even see it.
You're covering.
Wait.
Don't look at that.
I just realized it's...
Oh, wait.
Thank God you guys covered it.
Oh, nice.
You guys covered it.
Thank God.
I was gonna...
Because, like, when you hover, it shows, like, my...
It shows my numbers.
And I was like, don't look at it.
No.
Keep talking.
It covers it all.
You're the sensor.
So no one can see.
Um.
Whoa.
Okay.
Oh, look.
There's a Gundam.
Oh, my.
Okay.
The Gundam skins are really cool.
Wait.
I actually want to look at the Gundam skins.
Uh...
There you go.
What's this?
Whoa.
Too bad.
I'm gonna bat.
You're like, can't wait to show my Gundam skin.
It's so cool.
This mobile suit can defeat any enemy.
I'm the Grim Reaper.
Oh.
Wait.
I remember that Gundam.
It looks really good.
I think, like, Overwatch is really good at making nice skins.
And it has, like, community.
You can vote as a community, too, for the next skins and stuff, which is nice.
Oh, look at the...
It's that guy.
Good enough.
Yeah.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Broken Blonde.
Thank you for the $10.
Thank you.
This is for YouTube premium only, Doki.
No one should ever have to watch YouTube ads again.
But, yeah.
I think the Gundam skins look so good, honestly.
I think, like, every collaboration they do.
Like, you know, they did, like...
I know they did My Hero Academia.
They did Avatar.
They did...
Like, now they did Gundam.
They did so many that, like, it's hard to, like, keep track anymore.
But, I know, like, a lot of them are always...
Like, skins are, like, just really, really good.
And they're, like, very faithful to the adaptations.
And, like, especially the characters they pick.
You know, I definitely see Mercy as Gundam Wing Zero.
Honestly, a good pick.
Oh, yeah.
They did Cowboy Bebop.
They did Cowboy Bebop, too.
Oh, um...
What is this?
I actually want to watch this trailer for Stadium.
That was, like, one of the biggest...
The big launch they had.
So, for those who don't know, this is a new game mode that they have.
The new rank mode, as well.
Everyone says it's, like, incredibly fun.
So, um...
I've always been, like, curious and checking it out.
Because it's basically, like...
How do I explain it properly?
Um...
So, each round, you're in a different map, basically.
And I've seen gameplay of it.
And then you get to choose your loadout.
And you get to upgrade your loadout the more rounds you go.
You can play third person, but it's a choice.
It's first...
You can do first person or third person.
But it's basically a choice between the two.
Yeah, so there is, like, their own rank-up system to it, too.
And you can get competitive points from it.
Oh, and there's a new hero!
Apparently, she's really strong.
I mean, all launch heroes are really strong when they first come out.
Before they get nerfed.
Because they want people to play the hero, you know?
But she looks fun to play.
Which is nice.
I don't think she's available in rank yet.
And there's the band system.
Alright, guys.
Remember, exclamation point Overwatch.
And no more details.
I actually was thinking about it.
I was thinking about going back into rank.
Um, just...
Oh, there's Doki Watch!
That's me!
Oh, is she in rank right now?
Okay.
Is she OP in rank?
Yay!
That's me.
I'm all of them.
Oh, they get, like, their own transformations!
Oh, that is really maho shoujo.
Apparently, like...
Um...
All their skins have, like, unique...
Like, yeah.
Unique battle animations.
And stuff.
So, like, you know, like...
Juno with the hearts and everything.
And the flowers.
Oh, my God.
That...
Oh, you can have, like, do...
Different.
Jesus.
I...
Get in.
Do you want...
Sorry, I shouldn't.
I can't.
Doki, you can't say it.
By the way, you can give stuff now.
I believe.
Right?
You can...
You can give things now.
I'm sorry.
The Lone Rose gets plucked.
Oh, that's what I'm saying!
I love Abraxians.
They look so good.
2020 patch.
Mythic shop.
Oh, I didn't know about this.
Oh, I like this color scheme.
April 22nd.
Yeah!
That's when it all came out.
Oh, and then there's the Gundam collab.
Wow!
There it is.
Oh yeah, and then they have a little story too.
Hello!
Wait,
who's the evil one?
Oh, this is the story!
I miss Overwatch comics.
The Overwatch comics were like...
so interesting with the lore and stuff.
Remember when they first came out with the...
when they first like...
to hype up Overwatch, they had the little comics that they used to do.
And they build on the lore.
Someone to turn the tide...
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like a...
the Overwatch...
the Overwatch cinematics too.
Yeah, and the Overwatch cinematics too.
The enemy is closing in on her too.
She's in danger.
What are we waiting for?
Let's go!
I heard the stadium is like...
like everybody's playing the stadium now.
But I was thinking about coming back to rank just to...
check the new changes out with the purge system...
and see how far I could go.
Um...
but then I'm also like...
do I...
do I have enough in me?
To go...
to try and get top 500?
Do I have that in me?
to get through it?
Over time.
You're a lifesaver.
You looked quite stressed.
So I brought you a coffee.
Please cheer up, Edward.
Oh, Juno.
You're so thoughtful.
Thank you.
See, mother?
Five minutes was plenty.
Huh?
Mom!
Mother?
What's wrong?
Oh my god!
It's not like she's dead.
Wait, is that Evil D.Va?
Wait, is this D.Va?
When she wakes up, she'll be just like my new friends.
Her heart will be hollow.
Oh, so like...
Doki Watch is like love, and D.Va is like hate.
What do you want from her?
If evil, why hot?
And I'm not here for that old fat.
I'm here for you.
Oh!
Pew pew!
Stay behind me, Juno.
Rally our hearts!
Wait, is that Widow?
I would think Widow would be in the Nocturne.
I'm cleansing your mom of woe.
She's gonna be okay.
Don't worry, she'll have love in here again.
I promise we'll explain everything later.
Rally our hearts!
Get out of here first.
Kiriko, you ready?
Let my passionate heart guide you!
Oh, they recruited her like to the Doki Watch.
You need your power now!
They're like wake up!
I...
You do.
You're one of us.
A hero of heart.
That magitek you're holding will unlock your true potential.
All you have to do is...
Just believe in the power of friendship!
And believe...
Truly.
The classic magical girl moment.
I love how her little magical girl creatures are like little sharks.
Doki.
See!
Doki Doki!
That's where my name comes from!
It's me!
Doki Doki.
Oh my god.
Doki mention.
Oh no, there's like their little...
Their little like companions.
Don't make us do that.
We don't want to fight you anymore.
Come home.
We can still fix this.
No break.
It's too late.
Oh my gosh.
She's Sindere.
Wait.
Who's that?
Is that...
Excuse me.
I hope now...
Toxic Yuri.
We are the heroes of heart.
Protectors of the world.
Is he the...
I've done my job, but you didn't do anything.
Goodbye.
I'm Kiriko.
Heart of passion.
I'm Brigitte.
The heart of strength.
Amelie.
The heart of grace.
Amelie is...
Okay, yeah.
She is graceful.
The heart of courage.
And you are Juno.
The heart of hope.
Welcome to the heroes of heart.
Yay!
What a magical adventure.
Jokey watch.
Would that mean there would be like a part two?
That's cute though.
That's really cute.
I wonder if that means there would be like a part two.
Because who the heck was that guy that ran off with D.Va?
Is that...
Is that their tuxedo mask?
I'm just wondering.
All right.
Wait, I want to see the skins actually.
Oh yeah, guys.
Exclamation point overwatch.
By the way.
I need to pin that.
Guys, because I want to do exclamation overwatch for me real quick.
So I can pin the message.
Because the pin...
I didn't know how.
Why?
But pins expire.
But yes.
Exclamation point overwatch.
And if you click on the link, it really does help out a lot for me and the stream.
And the sponsor.
So there's the mercy one.
Okay, not gonna lie.
The Romacho one is really, really cool.
Wait.
Not him.
When he's like in the big form.
Him.
Not him.
I can take him.
Oh, I can customize it.
Oh, because it goes away.
Guys, I'm so dumb.
Manually.
All right.
There we go.
I figured it out.
Guys, you can tell I don't...
I'm not on Twitch often.
I...
But yeah.
Obviously, he looks really cool in this form.
I really like...
Wait.
Where are the...
Oh my god.
They actually used the Gundam sound effects.
That's actually cool.
The fact that they used the Gundam sound effects too.
Hey, what about like...
Yeah, it's like...
Some of the...
Some of the original sound effects from the anime.
Oh, okay.
I like the highlight intros.
Gotta go all out.
I mean, it's a collaboration.
So it makes sense that they're going all out.
For it.
Oh!
Okay.
The glow.
The eye glow.
And then you get the...
Oh, the pose and everything.
Come to hell with me.
Oh, Reaper.
Everyone who sees me will die.
Whoa.
Come to hell with me.
I mean...
If you say so, Mr. Reaper.
I...
Okay.
Sorry.
I...
Whoa!
You don't...
Okay.
What's the innocent?
You guys know.
Yeah.
Oh, that looks cool.
That looks really cool for the highlight intro.
Whoa.
Just twirling.
I'm learning.
Oh, yeah.
I want to look at the Doki Watch, too.
Dream...
Oh, wait.
What?
That skin is so cute.
Guys, I've always wanted to have, like...
One of the...
The...
The Doki Cinematic Universe.
I've always wanted to have a version of me where I'm just a sheep.
Because it's just...
I don't know.
I think sheep designs are really cute.
In general.
I think it's just like the eyes and the horns.
So there's...
What is this?
There's glitter?
Wait, who's glitter?
What...
What is she in the Doki Watch lore?
Is she just, like, the bundle?
Or...
Does she have, like, actual lore?
About herself?
Who is she in the Doki Watch Cinematic Universe?
She's just a girl...
Oh, it's...
Oh, it's a recolor!
Oh!
Okay, I was, like, confused.
I was like, where was Mei in the story?
Oh, and there's...
Oh my god, look at her hair.
Wait, what is that?
Oh my god, there's, like, a little spider at the end.
Oh, that's cute.
It's, like, a little spider.
And there's Heart of Passion.
Wait.
Oh, I want to see her.
You can try them out, by the way, in the practice range.
I know I should be checking out Stadium, but...
I'm always...
I always, like, looking at the cosmetic medics and stuff.
I don't know what...
I aim to defeat.
What?
Is there anything different with, like, her stuff?
Because I know, like...
The Juno thing looks different.
Oh my god, it's been so long since I've been here.
Can I...
Let's see...
Ooh!
Alright, is there...
Anything different?
No?
Okay, wait.
Let me do the ultimate and stuff.
Oh, is it the Juno?
Oh, it's the Juno Mythic!
Oh!
I thought it was, um...
I thought, like, the skin itself from each of the Doki Watch as something different.
Oh, I see.
I see.
The Juno Mythic.
Oh, and then there's Evil Diva.
And then there's Kiriko.
Wait, does that mean I can look at the Mythics, too?
Does that mean I can...
Oh, there it is!
Dome Chants.
There's all the Mythic stuff.
I was not here for a lot of the Mythic stuff, so...
Um...
I know, like, some of them are like...
Oh, there's the Iridescence!
The Mythic Aspects!
Oh!
Okay, these recolors look so good.
Like, are they for all the Mythic weapons, too?
Oh, I see!
Let's see.
And then there's...
The gold version of her.
Oh, so these are, like, all these stuff you can try out.
And, like, all the different combinations you can do.
And everything.
Oh, and then you can do, like, her gold version.
When she joins the dark side.
And then the other colors that she has.
And then you can change the...
Her bow gets bigger, you know?
When she gets stronger.
She has different hairstyles.
And everything.
Wait.
Okay.
I wanna see her...
Abilities.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, so...
Oh, it's, like, pink, too.
That's cute.
Oh!
It's a heart!
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
It's a little heart, too.
Oh, my God.
When you shoot it, it, like...
Makes a little, like, a bubble sound effect.
That's so cute.
That actually is really cute.
Makes you go doki doki!
What does it look like if I heal?
Whoop!
I...
They died.
Okay, where's my...
My heal?
Is my sense weird?
Or am I just not used to aiming?
Okay, that should not be my sense.
Stop!
Okay.
Guys, that definitely should not be my sense.
I was like, wait a minute.
Guys, what's my sense, guys?
Guys, I was like...
Oh, this feels weird.
Alright.
Oh, it is!
Okay.
It is.
Never mind.
I did not realize I played in that sense.
It's been a while.
Oh!
When I heal, it's...
It's a...
Circle!
It's a heart!
Okay, apparently that is my sense.
I was not...
I...
Oh, when I do this!
It's a heart.
Aw!
Cause I'm sending them love!
Threat neutralized.
Alright.
Feels so slow.
I'm gonna have to adjust my sense, cause it's been a while.
Alright, what does this look like?
In 2025, this is my ult.
This is...
Oh my god.
The love beam.
That's amazing.
That actually is amazing.
The power...
The power of...
I shall win my...
Guys, this is my top 500 game.
Guys, please.
This is my top 500, guys.
Woo!
Imagine getting top 500 with this.
The power of love will punish you.
Oh my god, coffee!
Thank you for the...
For the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
For those who are new here.
My name is Doki.
Today, I am sponsored by Overwatch.
So I am checking out the...
I am checking out the new...
The newest updates they have.
So like, stadium and everything.
It has been a very, very long time since I've been on Overwatch.
So...
So I'm just looking at all the new updates.
But thank you, everybody!
For showing up!
I'm usually on YouTube.
But today's a special Twitch day.
Uh...
Because of my sponsor today!
So yes!
Hello, everybody!
Welcome in!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, so that is the new Mythic Skins.
Mythic Skins are always...
I think it's such a...
Cool concept in Overwatch.
Um...
Especially for your favorite characters.
Cause I...
Remember like...
All of them have like...
Unique animations that you can do.
I know like...
Okay, so...
Especially when the high level you are.
Cause imagine the BM you can do with...
I love this one.
When I saw that, I thought that was so funny.
I...
The BM you can do on players.
That was the one...
When I saw this, when it came out, I was like...
Oh man, this is the one I actually...
This is the one I like the most.
Like...
But then obviously like...
The higher level your Mythic weapon is...
The crazier...
The death animations they are.
And stuff.
So like...
I think that one has always been like...
The more unique stuff you can do.
With the weapons.
I know there's like skins and weapons.
But the weapons are funny.
I don't know like...
Which one was this?
There was...
The Widow one.
There's like...
Oh yeah, you can do like...
In spec animations.
Oh yeah, there's like...
Unique in spec animations too.
Uh...
Okay, let me double check something real quick guys.
To make sure...
Oh yeah!
I forgot!
I was forgot about Freya!
Sorry guys.
There's so much new stuff that I haven't like...
I have never...
I haven't been able to check out.
Because it has been a while.
So let me go look at Freya!
And see...
How different she is compared to the other heroes.
Yeah, the new heroes!
Alright.
What does Freya have?
Where is Freya?
She is...
I believe a DPS.
Ooh!
Alright.
Details.
Rapidly fire automatic bolts.
Slow your momentum to take aim with high speed explosive bolts.
Using quick dashes.
Refreshes.
Take aim.
And...
Quick dash.
Okay, so...
Ball and you're moving.
And refresh.
Take aim.
Launch upward with a gust of wind.
Every three final blows gain bonus ultimate charge.
Oh, okay.
So...
The more DPS you do, the more you'll have all...
Fire an explosive bullet.
Hitting an enemy.
Wraps him up.
And pulls them in nearby enemies.
Hitting an enemy wraps them up and pulls them.
Okay, so it's like a Zarya ult.
Basically.
It's four and then one take aim.
Um, yeah.
I was gonna say, this is like a Zarya mini graph.
Damaging an enemy temporarily reduces their healing received.
Oh, this is a very...
This is scary.
If a good player uses her, she seems really strong.
Especially with the damaging enemy temporarily reduces their healing received.
So that's like anti-heal.
And then her other upgrades.
Enemy hits by three and quick are slowed by 20 seconds.
Real health enemies are revealed.
I feel like frost bolts are more important.
Frost bolts seem a lot of scary.
All DPS do that.
But like, a lot of DPS don't really have like...
This.
Though, this is the thing.
This is the most important part.
The...
Reducing your healing received is...
Very...
Anti-heal is always like the scariest thing you can deal with.
Especially if they have freeze too.
Like slow as well.
Um...
Oh, is it all passive for all DPS?
Oh, it's all DPS now?
Oh.
That's new.
I didn't realize.
This is for all damage heroes.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's...
Really scary.
See, this has been a long time since I touched...
Oh, that's scary.
That's...
That and also Freya has...
Uh...
Frost...
This thing is always...
Uh...
Not great.
Alright.
Grants a temporary free use.
A quick dash.
Direct use.
Would take aim.
Refunds.
Four automatically.
I don't know which one to get.
Alright.
So what?
It's like...
Okay.
I can't count.
Alright.
Let's make sure we have...
All our perks.
Alright.
And...
How do I do perk?
Okay.
Left alt.
It's left alt.
Alright.
Slow.
I would like my slow please.
And...
Which would be good?
Ready to hunt?
Or relentless?
Relentless barrage.
And that grants a temporary free use.
A quick dash.
Direct hit with...
Take aim.
Refunds.
Four automatically.
Is it barrage?
It's auto reload.
Oh!
Okay.
So there's that.
And then there's the dash.
I have two dashes.
Okay.
So it's two dashes.
So...
Twelve bullets.
Okay.
One, two, three, four.
One,
two, three, four.
Okay.
If I can do...
Yeah.
It feels like infinite ammo.
And then she has a lot of mobility too.
Okay.
Oh.
So I have to hook...
Okay.
So I have to...
I was trying to see if it works.
If...
What...
How it does when I don't hit it.
But...
I guess like the...
The...
When the mini graph happens if I hit the person.
So...
Yeah.
That's...
Scary.
Oh.
The E and then the...
Take aim.
Ooh.
All right.
Let's see if...
What happens when I hit him.
Okay.
So I...
That's a short range for the ult.
I'm getting very technical right now.
Like my overwatch brain is like...
Like cooking at the moment.
So...
Okay.
So the range is really small though.
For her ult.
Yeah.
It's a...
It's a baby grab.
She seems fun to play though.
She seems really fun to play.
In general.
Yeah.
Fair enough.
Short but lots of mobility.
Yeah.
The...
The infinite ammo is like...
Really strong if we get builded up to there.
I heard in stadium.
You can basically build a mercy player that never dies.
Is blue.
Because like...
You know how I said you build traits and stuff?
So...
It's like...
It's like a MOBA.
So...
In...
It's like a MOBA where you...
Like...
You build traits and stuff to upgrade yourself.
Each...
Like...
While the round is going on.
And then there's like moments where you can build a mercy player that...
Um...
That can never die.
Especially when she...
She can res and stuff.
And take like...
10 million damage.
Yeah.
Some stadium builds go absolutely crazy.
And you can build like...
An actual...
Raid boss.
Uh...
For supports.
Here from stadiums.
From what I've heard.
I have not reloaded.
Oh, there you go.
There's those.
There you go.
I messed up my...
I messed up my perk.
And now I've reloaded.
That was the...
I felt like that was the first reload I did.
Just now.
Healers never die.
Woo!
That sounds really scary.
Because if I can do that as a support for...
Stadium.
It makes me wonder what kind of builds you can do.
As a...
As like DPS and tank.
Does that...
How tanky...
It's like...
How tanky is a...
Can a tank be?
If you can build like...
An almost invincible support player.
Like...
How far can the HP go?
Yay!
I...
I enjoy...
I enjoy the gunplay...
Of Freya.
Actually...
Really wanna try Freya in quick play.
I really enjoy her...
Gunplay.
Let's see.
Makes me feel like I'm a good player.
That's...
Guys, I miss hitscan.
You know...
I love hitscan.
It actually...
It actually makes me feel like I'm a good player.
Playing Freya.
But...
To be fair.
I am on a...
Practice range.
So...
Let's see how I feel in quick play.
Haha!
Will I feel the same way?
Will I...
Will I feel the same way in quick play?
If I try to play her?
I...
Is she not hitscan?
She feels like hitscan.
Her bullets feel...
Feel...
Really fast.
Is she...
Is she projectile?
Her bullets feel like as fast as a hitscan.
Or is there like...
She's a fast projectile.
Oh!
Okay.
Just really fast projectiles.
Alright!
Let's see how I feel.
It's been a while.
I'm also a little sick too.
An aim down slight...
Single ball...
Okay!
So her aim down is slower.
It's fast at least.
Yeah, her...
I thought it was hitscan because it felt really, really fast.
So we'll see how it goes.
Where are skins any...
Oh, I don't have any.
Haha!
I was like, let's see their skins!
And I was like, oh wait, I don't have any of the skins.
I...
She just came out.
Alright.
And if...
If I can't play her...
Oh, I hate defense.
Oh!
Why?
No!
They took...
My legs!
I was gonna say my backup was legs.
Backup was gonna be legs if I can't do...
If I can't play Freya.
Alright, I guess I have to climb up.
Oh my god, it's been so long.
It's been so long!
Let's see how this goes.
I feel like a baby right now.
Haha!
Oh, I feel like a little baby trying to play...
Play Overwatch again.
Sojourn is just Freya with less steps.
Bro, I'm bad at Sojourn.
That's not good for me.
Oh wait, someone already has...
Wait, someone already has the mythic skin.
It's crazy.
Guys, please.
Please, let me see you.
Oh, it is slow.
I see the slow.
I see the slowness now.
Where's my I need healing?
This is very important.
Yeah.
Right click is slow.
There we go.
That's fine.
Woo!
Yep.
Alright, now I see it.
Where is he?
For some reason, I feel like I could hover, but I can't.
Click, click, click.
I like this.
Oh fuck!
Oh shit!
I don't know why I expected to get heals.
Alright.
Whoops.
The sound is very satisfying though, when I go like...
Pew pew pew pew pew.
Okay legs, why are you not doing damage?
How am I getting more ult charge than you?
What are you doing legs?
Do your job!
Oh my god.
I know.
Okay, never mind.
He's catching up now.
He's catching up.
Oh, she's weak to hit scan focus.
That's good to know.
Bro, it is peaceful.
Guys, don't worry.
I keep thinking I can float down.
I don't know why.
There's something in there that makes me think I can...
Please, there's so many things going on.
Why?
Oh my god, you're right.
No, it's fine.
I just need warm up.
Can't believe it.
Guys, like I said...
No, never mind.
I was gonna say I was gonna play someone else, but...
I keep thinking I can float down.
And that's like messing me up.
What?
Oh my god, he's won!
Wait, how did this do it?
It was fine.
Oh, DPS makes me have to focus so much!
Oh!
I don't know why, but...
Oh, okay.
What was it?
Frost, yeah.
Guys, I forgot how much I have to focus when I play DPS.
Oh!
I need to actually think!
Please, he's won!
No!
He looked at me!
The hitscat looked at me!
Please, soldier, use your ult!
Oh my god, it's not that difficult to ult!
You're a soldier!
Please, I almost built another ult while waiting for you!
I'm trying to figure out the speed!
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's fine, I killed one.
I...
I'm just saying, our soldier should at least ult.
Worth it.
He's waiting.
When will it ever be the right moment?
Oh my god, he's right here, I can hear him.
When will it ever be the right moment for you?
Please!
Oh my god, you're welcome!
You're welcome!
Okay.
That's fine.
This is not fine.
That's not fine!
Soldier, please!
That was your ult!
I have to!
Bro, none of my team has perks for me!
I...
Okay, look.
All I'm saying is, I'm not the problem.
I'm...
I'm not the problem.
I know I'm not the problem.
I need to use this for healers.
Oh my god, please.
I can't go on point, guys.
I'm not the problem.
I'm not the problem, guys.
Okay.
Not me!
I'm doing my job!
I'm not...
I don't know.
All I'm saying...
Not me.
Alright.
I'm mad.
I'm...
Let me play a different DPS character that I'm very familiar with to...
Be less mad.
And then I'll go back to Freya.
Alright.
Don't worry.
And then...
The moment...
I play the other character, I'll go back to Freya.
Alright.
Oh, man.
All I'm saying is our soldier waited so long to make the perfect play...
On his ultimate.
And he still...
He did it all.
And I was like, soldier, what were you waiting on?
Okay, guys.
Who is the meta DPS?
Am I not player?
Because...
Alright.
I'll play soldier.
Actually, let me just play legs real quick.
I have a lot of...
Actually...
I think Strike Commander is my favorite skin.
Freya is meta.
I'm not surprised.
She builds her ult really, really fast.
Soldier...
I mean, soldier is always really strong.
You can aim.
Okay.
What is meta in high elo?
You guys don't have to tell me...
I...
Because there's a difference between meta and...
And...
In low elo and meta in high elo.
What is...
What is strong in high elo?
It's so dirty.
Okay.
You ass like I play rank.
Soldier.
There's...
No way.
Is Torva actually?
Okay.
Alright.
It's been a while since I've...
I don't know what perks were soldier though.
I should have looked at the perks for soldier.
Oh my god.
Of course, Ashe.
Click, click, click.
I forgot what it was like to aim in Overwatch though.
It's been so long.
Wait.
They're just walking to point.
Hahaha.
Wait.
Where did they go?
Just gonna let them walk on point?
Where did my tank go?
You just gonna let them walk up?
Tank!
Get back on high ground!
What you doing?
Oh my god.
He just dropped down and never came back up.
He's a farmer.
Oh no!
He right clicked me!
My bad.
I forgot to...
I ego peeked him.
I was like, there's no way he hits that right click.
The high ground is for cowards!
Like, all I'm saying is if he was...
If he was there on high ground with me, I'd get my own personal shield.
But I didn't.
I didn't, so I have to peek like a pussy.
Sorry, like a...
Like a scared little girl.
I have to remember.
I can not be as toxic.
Alright.
Aiming in this game is so different.
Like, as a DPS.
I'm not used to it.
Because this has been...
Oh, I don't want to get...
I don't want to get headshot!
I don't
want to get headshot!
What are you doing?
Get down here.
Oh!
What do you mean you're out of ammo?
You can reload whenever!
Oh, goodbye.
Where is she?
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, we don't have supports right now.
Oh, no, I'm slow.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm okay.
I can't do my perk system.
I'm alive!
Oh, very useful ult.
Guys, don't worry.
Very useful.
Zoning ult!
Oh!
Don't buy...
Okay.
Uh, Helix biotic is increased by...
If they reload 50, they damage an enemy?
I don't know.
Guys, it's called zoning ult.
You don't...
I know you guys might not have seen it, but it's very crucial in high elo play.
Guys, everybody does it in high elo.
You don't understand.
What is he doing?
Oh my god.
The classic.
No!
I was just trying to...
The classic.
Run around in a circle.
So they can't hit me.
It's the Overwatch classic.
Sick head down movement.
It can't get me.
It can't get me if I run...
Oh.
If I run down.
And look at the floor.
Where's the map?
Look at...
No!
It's an actual strat!
Overwatch invented it!
It's the classic!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Alright, it's fine.
I'm gonna focus actually on aiming.
There we go.
Oh, what the?
I'm gonna die for this.
But that's fine.
I'm okay.
It was worth it!
It was worth- It works!
It's an actual- I've been playing Overwatch since Overwatch 1!
It's a real strat!
What are you talking about?
Everyone does it!
Okay.
What?
It's like, they can't hit you if you just look at the ground.
It's dumb, but like, it's true.
Jesus.
Hello, guys.
Hi.
Hello, everybody.
Guys.
Please.
No.
Goddammit.
There we go.
Okay, nice.
See, we're alive!
I told you!
What's that sound?
Oh, that's that sound.
Don't worry.
I'm back.
I have legs.
I keep running and I'll keep living.
Oh, I'll keep running and I'll keep living.
That's how it works.
Should I just stay here?
And just stay here.
Oh, I can't stay here!
Please, I'm right here.
Please.
They don't know.
Oh, my God.
I can stay here.
No, they don't know.
I can stay.
Oh, my God.
This is not fair.
You got heals.
I got you one HP five different times.
I...
I got you.
It's not fair.
Oh, my God.
What is it like to have healings?
I got...
It's not fair.
Oh, my God.
What is it like to be healed?
It's fine.
I got him.
That's okay.
Hello.
Oh, my God.
I got my one.
How much more do I have to ask for heals?
I can't believe it.
Oh, my God.
I almost got like...
Hello, guys.
I'll just stay here for now.
I forgot to have crouch button.
I knew it.
I knew I'm forgetting something.
I was like, wait a minute.
I can crouch.
Jesus.
Zoning again.
I knew I forgot something.
It makes you more unpredictable.
Oh, my God.
I'm okay.
Okay.
I knew I forgot something, though.
I was like, wait a minute.
I forgot something in my kit.
It's okay.
Get down.
Oh!
He ulted me!
Okay, look.
I think I am doing my job.
Oh, man.
I should have went Tracer.
Please.
I'm on point.
Just heal me.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Just a little bit of heal.
I got one each round.
Did you not kill him?
How did you not kill him?
He was one!
I got him one!
I...
Oh, man.
You...
Oh, my God.
Oh.
I did my job.
I did...
Alright.
Back to Freya.
I was satisfied with...
with my kills.
I did...
I pulled my weight.
That's enough.
Guys, I will check out Stadium.
Guys, I just see it...
get warmed up with DPS real fast.
I was gonna use the back, y'all.
Be right back.
Arriving at Yijang Tower.
Select your hero.
Alright, I'm back.
Also, this is like...
someone actually...
during my convention at...
um...
Tokyo Alley, in Australia.
Someone asked me like, oh, why don't you stream my DPS?
And the reason why I don't, is because like, whenever I play DPS...
um...
When I play DPS, my brain is so overloaded...
with things I have to do as DPS...
versus as support...
that it's so hard to like, talk to you guys...
when I'm playing DPS...
because I'm like...
I...
my brain is like, trying to...
kill.
like...
I have...
I have to focus on like...
killing things...
and...
while support, I can just be like...
it's so...
it's just easier...
It's...
I DAREWINSTON!
oh my god...
okay.
It's...
it's easier to actually...
It's just easier to like...
oh my god...
It's much easier to like, get...
like talk and interact with chat...
when I'm not trying to focus on getting headshots...
Like, I was like, my brain was like, how to talk.
Oh my god, team, are you guys okay, team?
I love hitscan.
Hitscan fun.
Sorry.
There we go.
Hitscan fun.
Why would you go Pharah?
They have an Ashe.
Are you dumb?
Wait, you're not.
Like, are you dumb?
Oh, goddammit.
I got, I got really, uh, what's the word?
I got very cocky there.
I need to remember that I can crouch.
Juno!
Juno, please!
Also, I play support because, like, stuff like this kills me.
Uh, regen for each enemy target.
For an hammer individual.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's good.
I got really greedy there.
Hello.
Please.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, no.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh my god, where's the dragon?
There he is.
No!
I got greedy!
I got so greedy!
I was like, I don't...
He's not gonna hit that shot.
Oh my god.
My brain is not ready for this.
My brain...
That's right.
Peek me.
Oh my god, not like that.
Not like that.
No!
Please!
I was right behind you!
Just a little bit of crumb!
That's all I ask!
A little bit of heal crumb!
Please!
Don't make me go support!
I also go support when I get mad with lack of heals.
I'm swapping off Kass.
I'm sorry!
Daddy's angry!
I can't!
I just rolled Q!
What are they on?
I don't remember.
Because I don't think... No, they're on Hanzo.
They were so grouped up.
I was gonna say, I could have played Tracer.
It's fine.
Look.
Guys, it's animated.
I have a lot of the animated ones.
Look.
This one I know life this game.
I mean, I'm hitting my shots, though.
I'm hitting my shots.
It's just that... I just need a little bit more heal.
That's it.
I literally just need heals.
And then I can live.
Like, I have to play next to my healers.
I'm lucky.
Wait.
Where's our team?
I'm lucky.
Oh, he's so low.
Nice.
I got him.
No.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
The Ana actually healed me.
I'm so happy.
Hey, what do I want?
Casting throws that travels both.
Griddle hits reduces the cooldown of combat rule.
Wait.
Is that good?
Let's try.
I don't know what...
Wait.
They hacked it.
Oh, no.
What was that?
Nice.
Oh.
I forgot.
My oldest just cosmetic.
Okay.
Where would he go?
Oh, the Hanzo can hack the pack?
I was like...
They have Sombra?
I was so confused.
I was like wondering if that was a Sombra.
Oh, he was one.
And they say...
I feel like he has...
Yep.
What?
I was behind it!
Are you serious?
I was behind it.
I refuse to believe I was not behind it.
I knew he had...
There we go.
I...
No!
Not the orb!
Yeah, I was like...
When did Hanzo know how to hack?
Alright.
I don't need perks.
I just gotta be fast.
Just mora things, you know?
Just little...
Just little mora things.
There we go.
Oh, I forgot one more round.
Oops.
I forgot one more round!
Oh, it's okay.
Okay.
So...
I don't know the...
I don't...
I don't know the distance for the melee combo.
It's been...
Too long.
A good tracer knows the melee combo for blinks and I don't...
I don't...
But I'm not a good tracer.
Why are even my perks for this one?
Can I see it?
What is it?
What...
Okay, guys.
Tell me what perks to get!
Right now!
Tell me!
Guys!
Overwatch veterans!
What perks?
1-1?
Okay.
I believe.
Left, left.
Okay, I believe.
Alright.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Unlock.
Wait, they win!
Oh my god.
They win Cassidy!
That's not fair!
They actually win Cassidy.
Okay, that's fine.
I can't believe they win Cassidy.
Okay.
That's bad for me.
There you go.
Aw, you're a bitch if you need that to just to...
Oh, you're such a bitch!
Ooof!
Hahaha.
Hahahaha.
He hr.
Oh.
I like tracer only because of tracking.
I'm not the best Tracer player, obviously.
Oh, you're pranked now!
Counter me more, please!
Please!
Please counter me more!
Jesus Christ!
Oh, man.
Fine.
I am actual cowards.
All I'm saying is they clearly... There we go.
Oh, my god.
I'm not gonna live.
I know I'm not gonna live, so I'm like, I'm just stalling as much as I can.
There's no way for me to live!
Oh, they just got... It's fine.
No!
He was so close!
Alright.
Okay, I have to swap.
They are full-on countering me.
I'm sad.
I wanted to play Tracer!
Come on!
I'm regrouping.
I'm sad.
Oh, my god.
Really?
There's nothing I can do.
You got the health pack, too.
No!
It's not fair!
I have to swap!
You guys suck!
I want to play Tracer!
No fun.
Actual no fun.
We don't have anybody in touch, though.
Yeah.
You guys suck!
I just want to play Tracer!
Just play Tracer!
Don't die!
They went...
Cast and Brig and Morag... I mean, they went Brig and that's when I couldn't do anything anymore.
I couldn't do anything after that!
To stadium gel with you!
No!
Okay, but what if I do one more?
What if I do one more?
What if I do one more quick flip?
You know what?
I'll do either.
I'll do either because I got a little tilted at our supports.
Guys, you know when I do stadium!
When I do stadium, you know what gel I'm...
Wait, actually, no.
We get to see support when we're in stadium.
We get to see support when we're in stadium!
This is a rare moment where I can play DPS.
This is a rare moment.
Alright, let's try it.
I always deliver.
When I play stadium, you know what gel I'm gonna be in!
Oh, wait, he's bad.
Okay.
Oh, no, that's not what I wanted.
Oh, whoops.
Oh my god, that Lucio threw me off.
Lucio made me look at him!
I was like, what was that?
Alright.
That's fine.
How do I have long road queue for it?
What is this Lucio doing?
This is deathmatch!
The Lucio destra- Oh, no!
Got the venture out of nowhere!
Oh, no!
He can't do anything!
He's hacked!
No.
How dare you!
There we go.
Yeah!
Alright, finally I'm getting killed.
I'm remembering how to crouch spam, guys.
It's been a long time, but...
Are you serious?
Okay, there you go.
It's been a while, but I can crouch spam down.
Oh my god.
At least, like, it makes it harder for them to aim.
Everyone should play torpedo?
Who's torpedo?
But it's been a while.
But I'm getting my muscle memory back.
Oh.
Okay, who- Who the heck plays hog?
In deathmatch?
What are you doing?
I hate hog players in deathmatch.
Oh, torpedo Juno?
Wait, okay.
You guys gotta teach me.
You guys gotta teach me the right builds.
Alright.
Okay, I'll do Freya, and then I'll do stadium.
Right after.
I saw you got hacked by Sombra and gave me PTSD.
Okay, okay.
After this, I'll do stadium.
It's Freya time.
I'm satisfied with the last two DPS games.
Okay, so what do you do for a torpedo Juno?
Give me the most...
Most broken builds you can do in stadium.
Wait.
How busted is it?
Okay, guys.
You gotta teach me.
Basically, Ability, Damage, Fast, Torpedo, Cooldown.
Stack Ability, Power?
I heard, like, there's so many busted builds.
All right, and then you guys teach me the busted Juno build.
I wanna try that out.
She nanos the whole team?!
Okay, we're doing that.
We're doing that after Juno torpedo build.
We're right after that.
That sounds amazing.
That sounds insane.
Okay, our tank's dead.
All right.
Why did he...
How did he die so fast?!
Oh my god.
Poor guy.
Okay.
He's here.
Oh no.
No.
Here, go, please!
Okay.
All right.
Oh.
Let me try...
Hey, at least I'm building up really, really fast.
Because he's my ult battery.
All right.
All right, I got it.
Nice.
All right.
I can see the appeal now.
When they're all...
grouped up like that.
Nice.
All right, what's up?
Okay, frost bolts is actually bad.
Wait, have we not killed the hog?
Bro, what?
Where's the hog?
Who just let him walk away like that?!
What?!
He's just standing there!
Oh no, not the mercy.
Not the...
Strong ass mercy res.
He doesn't even have Valk!
Oh no, but she brought back the hog.
The raid boss.
All right, here we go.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
My team's dead.
That's okay.
Please, Ana, please.
I'm right in front of you, Ana.
Please.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
This...
I'm actually getting healed, guys.
It's actually crazy.
I don't know how that feels.
Oh!
Never mind.
I got headshot.
I...
I got...
I got headshots.
That's okay.
I...
Healing doesn't save me from headshots.
Apparently.
Cannot heal that.
Oops.
I almost felt like a guy.
I was getting healed.
Oh my god.
We finally killed a raid boss.
You thought you...
Never mind.
I didn't break it.
Okay.
Sorry, I timed it incorrectly.
I thought my...
I thought I did more damage.
I...
It should work.
Theoretically.
But it didn't.
That's fine.
Excellent timing.
I messed up a little.
Haha.
Weeeee.
That was painful.
I got hooked.
Classic Overwatch.
Some things never change, you know?
Some things just never change.
Okay, on.
Oh.
Just like that.
Some things just never change.
A slight miscalculation.
Okay, but this Freya gameplay is a lot better than the first time I played Freya.
I'm a little bit more warmed up now.
And if I have to, I will play Reaper because this hog is pissing me off.
If I have to.
I will play.
I will play Reaper.
Hello soldier, can I borrow some heals?
Alright.
No.
That's fine.
Thank you.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, I got it.
Whoa!
Jesus Christ.
Alright, that's it.
Okay, after I ult.
After I ult.
Uh, grants temporary free use.
Oh yeah, the four unlimited ammo.
Alright.
Wait, is hog not in stadium?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, okay.
I was looking at chat.
Wait, is hog not in stadium?
Is it like a predetermined match of heroes?
I don't care.
I want him.
Are you so- Oh my god!
Oh my god!
You know what?
Alright, stop.
Angry.
He tamed it.
Oh, since there is a limited pull up.
Oh, I see.
Angry.
I don't remember how I play Reaper.
It's only D.Va, right?
Okay.
Not that bad, right?
It doesn't seem that bad.
Oh wait, but they capped.
So I don't know what...
I shall counter play.
Alright, guys.
How's the perks for this?
It's not fair.
Hey, where's the health packs for this?
Please heal me.
I'm scared.
Farm him!
He's an old battery!
Keep farming him!
He's enough- Oh, goodbye.
I can't shoot that.
Alright, that's fine.
Our tank died.
I really need that.
No, you don't understand.
I do.
Guys, left or right?
Left or right?
Right, right.
Okay.
I know my main goal with Sif.
Oh.
Hello.
Are you though?
Oh my gosh, she was.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I got anti.
That 8 HP was a huge difference.
You don't understand.
I thought he was more of a tank trader.
To be fair, tanks are like 8,000 HP now.
I didn't remember.
This matters.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Ogg.
I needed that.
I... Yippee!
Oh.
Was it right?
Right, right.
I didn't even read what my perks are.
I didn't even read it.
I was just like... Very helpful.
It really was.
I appreciate it.
Where do I go?
Like... I guess I'll... I'll just shoot him from here.
Oh my god.
This hog is crazy though.
Like, actually.
This hog is insane.
Like... Oh my god.
What is he doing?
These hooks are crazy.
You know what's funny?
Their Ana didn't care.
Oh my god.
I... What?
What happened to me?
I got like everything off.
It's okay.
Okay.
My team did it.
Oh, she got...
Ana took that firstly.
I mean, their Ana let their Hanzo die.
Like, I... I don't know.
I'm just speaking facts there.
And then this Mercy just gracefully glided.
This Mercy just gracefully glided like that.
Like, I don't know what he was doing.
Alright.
Oh, no.
Goddamn stupid Hanzo.
I'm leaving.
Hello.
Hello, guys.
Let me be behind your shield.
Oh.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I'm right here.
Oh, thank you.
Jump rat.
Oh, goodbye.
No.
He put me so far.
So far.
Oh.
That's unlucky for him.
It's okay.
This is always the strat when we're about to push point.
Overtime strat.
I told you.
The overtime strat.
It always works.
Overtime strat always works.
The good old Bastion.
The good old Bastion strat at the very end.
The...
Yippee.
Oh, that's when I swapped the Bastion.
Let's go.
Yippee.
Overtime strat.
All my homies hate surprise Bastion.
All right.
It's time.
Stadium.
Oh, yeah.
So, by the way, there is, like, rank, by the way, for this.
I remember telling...
Wait.
Change.
Okay.
Stadium.
Roll Q.
I am basically a baby.
We're not doing damage.
I don't trust myself.
So, the stadium is the newest thing that they added to Overwatch 2.
And...
They have, like...
It's, like, a whole new different mode.
And they have their own ranking system for it, too.
So, you can get competitive points and everything in the stadium.
And...
Oh, these are all the characters.
All right, guys.
The Juno.
Oh, my God.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Guys.
Okay.
What do I get?
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Okay.
This is a lot.
Oh, ho, ho.
All right, guys.
So, what is the torpedo build?
What is...
Basically, this build.
Is it this build?
Do I just get all of these?
All right.
Gains one additional charge.
Heal for...
Missiles and AP.
So, I just do this build.
This is where the fun...
Just get everything that says torpedo and ability power.
So, all of these?
Torpedo.
All of...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay.
Power.
Torpedo.
Okay.
Pull up the spreadsheet.
Guys, you gotta teach me what build to get, guys.
You gotta teach me.
There's so...
Okay.
So, I get all the abilities here.
Where is torpedo?
You can get, like, four...
Okay.
But, like, what is the torpedo build?
How do I do it?
I'm queuing up, guys.
I'm just practicing.
I gotta practice my build.
What do we build first?
This will do me fine?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, I got a game.
I was like, what?
I got concerned.
I was like, what happened?
Time to do it live, I guess.
Time to figure this out live.
Yeah, this is my first stadium game, by the way.
My very first one.
I almost picked the wrong support, too.
Because I'm so used to double clicking.
Okay.
I'm ready.
No think only.
Guys.
I looked at...
I looked at the stuff I have to do, guys.
And I don't know if no think only do is applicable for stadium.
I...
With the amount...
Power up your build.
Choose from two example builds to get started.
Explore all the options.
Customize, sell, and count it.
React and adapt to your enemy.
So it's like, basically a MOBA and a healer shooter.
So...
Alright.
So, is it okay if I start with Power Pulse?
Or do I do it with anything else?
Reforcing it.
Guys.
I don't know.
I...
Alright.
And then I'll do...
This.
What if I just build everything right now?
I'll just do all of this.
And I can sell this.
And then do that.
Right?
I have enough.
Okay.
Whoa.
Alright.
Just click torpedo and AP.
Eat.
Alright.
I can do this.
We got this.
I believe, guys.
It's torpedo time.
Alright.
I think I got it.
Wait.
Can't you change it to...
Can't you change it to the first person?
I thought you can...
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's try...
Let's try third person.
Whoa.
Oh.
There's a reason why we try third person.
I don't know what the elo is for this one.
Because I don't have a rank.
I don't have a rank for this one.
Where do we have to go?
Oh.
It's a new map, too.
It's so weird watching this in.
Okay.
My team's dead already?
Alright.
That's cool.
I think I understand what elo I'm in.
Get out of here.
I'm better.
I
get my torpedo so fast.
I just...
Guys.
I...
This is...
This is not fair.
I just realized how fast I get it.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
I build ults so slow, though.
That's what I don't like right now.
When do I start...
When can I buy stuff?
Get out of here.
Get out of here, team!
But, like, when can I...
Can I upgrade my build when...
Uh...
In between rounds or...
Oh, wait.
Whoops.
Can I...
Do I upgrade my build in between rounds or can I do it when I die?
I'll keep him up.
Mercy.
I...
Oh, my God.
Okay.
This is, like, the only way to keep us alive right now.
Oh, no.
No!
I couldn't do anything!
My ult got one down!
And our rounds.
Okay.
I just have every...
That's good to know.
Get over here, Mercy.
Don't worry!
Oh, never mind.
Worry!
Mercy, how?
How?
Please!
I have one dead!
I don't know if I have one playing third person or a first person yet.
It is, like, different.
So...
Okay, nice.
The speed with the Reaper ult.
You're there?
That's not good?
There you go.
Nice.
I didn't know when to crouch.
I'm trying to do as much as I can.
Okay.
I'm about to, like, get as much damage as our Reaper.
So I know our Reaper is not doing shit.
But I might not also not be healing very well.
No, I am.
I'm healing.
Wait, no.
No, I'm healing more than our Mercy.
Mercy, what?
I'm healing more than you?
Mercy!
Go fast.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
No, I can't do anything!
Mercy!
He just...
He was at the left click, Mercy!
Guys, I understand hero bans now.
I...
Guys, I understand.
All I'm saying, I should not be...
I...
I don't know.
Now I know.
How many rounds is it, too?
Oh, seven!
It's seven.
Okay.
Let's see.
It's late game.
That's better.
All right.
And then all I have to do is...
Do I buy all of these?
No, it's seven, apparently, right?
Just buy all of these and it's okay?
Yeah?
All right.
Let me revoid this.
10% ability...
Oh, I have lifesteal.
Gain over health ability.
20%.
Oh.
I don't have enough money for this.
I'm broke.
Wait, should I get this one over the other?
Uh...
Oh, I'll just keep this.
I'll build power goes healing and damage.
How do I go back to my store?
Oh, here.
Oh, how do I go back to my armory, though?
Oh, H.
Okay.
Um...
I'll do this first, then.
If I can sell the greens?
Okay, I'll sell...
I'll do that next round and sell the greens.
I'm just following the example builds they give me.
I can see why there's, like, a lot you can do.
Refurb, thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Search up.
Thank you for the thousand biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Boom.
All right.
How strong am I now?
I believe, like...
This is all rank, right?
There's no actual quick play for Stadia.
I'll put that in.
Okay, so Mercy is only good when...
Very late build.
I now know that.
Okay.
Don't worry, Mercy.
I got you.
Okay, you got...
I still got you.
I have to reload, though.
Don't worry.
I'm helping.
Look at that.
I helped.
I have no idea what my ELO is, because I have never...
I've never played Stadia before.
But, like...
This is, like, spreadsheet worthy.
Like...
I'm, like...
Like, this is definitely, like, stuff you need a spreadsheet for.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
What are you doing, Reaper?
What are you...
Oh, my God.
Reaper!
There's something!
Reaper everywhere!
Okay.
I need to, like...
Oh, that Arborist is good, though.
There you go.
We fight this.
What?
That out-damages my ult?
It out-damages my ult?
My ult?
It...
Oh, my God.
That strength.
I did use it.
Unless...
I don't have speed boost.
Good luck.
Okay.
I can't believe it, like, actually out-damages...
Out-damages my own, like, healing ult.
Guys, use this to...
Oh, okay.
Or to go forward.
That is a...
That is truly a decision.
Okay.
Nice.
I still don't know which...
I should try...
I'm gonna try first person after this round.
Nice.
Oh, it's overtime.
Oh, it's one.
Nice.
We did it!
Orsa, no, thank.
Only one.
Nice.
Okay.
I have...
Let's see.
Okay.
I'm doing less damage.
I'm actually focusing on healing now, guys.
Look at that.
I'm focused on healing now, guys.
I did it.
Okay, Mr. Tiny Man.
You have the lowest damp.
Shush.
You are not doing anything right now.
All right.
Do we sell?
We should sell.
Okay.
10% lifesteal.
Ability.
Power.
Lifesteal.
We have enough?
7,000.
If I sell this, 8,000.
9,000.
10.
If I sell all three of this to get this, is it worth it?
I'll do it.
Shush, Reaper.
Look at...
I know what your damage was.
You've already seen so much action, and there's still more to come.
This guy.
Don't make me open your profile.
Don't...
Don't make me open your profile, Mr. Tiny Man.
Don't make me open it.
I saw your KDA, buddy.
I...
Listen here, canvas.
Canvas.
3, 2, 1.
Good.
Commencing attack on Objective B.
All right.
Bite size!
Thank you for 10 gifted subs!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
Okay.
What the fuck are they doing over there?
What the fuck?
What the...
Oh, no.
Nice.
No!
I got...
I...
That was high ego.
I egoed that.
God damn it.
I wanted to kill their Mercy so bad.
Oh, hey.
I got res.
Nice.
Yippee!
Okay.
Nice.
I got focused so much for these.
No!
Nice.
I got focused so much.
Okay.
Jesus...
This is so much.
There's so much stuff going on.
Oh, my God.
I...
I have to be so focused for this.
The objective goes live in town.
Please.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
Sorry, guys.
I have to be so focused when I'm playing this game mode.
It's actually crazy how focused I have to be.
No!
Oh, my God.
I had to do so much.
I did so much.
Please.
Jesus Christ.
Nice.
I can't do anything.
Okay.
Oh, wait, Cass, what are you doing, Cass?
Get back here!
Okay.
Nice.
That's bad.
That's unlucky for us.
I actually was on high ground.
What?
That hits me!
I flew up too!
I actually flew up.
I can't believe it.
I flew up for that too.
Let's check the standings.
One, two, two.
Oh my god.
Damn.
The range for that.
True, thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you.
All I'm saying is our Reaper is like 3k.
Like, it's not... It's... That's all I'm saying.
Our Reaper is at 3k damage.
And I would... And use that.
Um... Please use your E ability, Juno.
Um... Please, like, kill people, Reaper.
I... Welcome to Stadium.
Yeah.
There's a big difference between the two Reapers.
100%.
I agree.
I have the second... Wait, what is... Okay.
I need to use my money.
Alright.
Should I... I should have enough.
I'll just grab... Ability Power.
Um... Do your job, Reaper.
Oh, yeah.
Try... What was it?
Options.
Settings.
How do I do it?
Where's first person, guys?
Stadium.
Okay.
Let's try first person.
I'm curious.
Oh, my God.
Everything is so zoomed in now.
Alright.
I wanna try this.
I'm curious.
Oh!
What is that?
Is that the camera?
Oh, this is... I think... Never mind.
I get why this third person is good for this.
I... Guys, I understand why third person is good.
I understand.
This is a lie.
It's...
It's actually so much.
Okay.
What the heck is the Reaper doing?
What are you...
What are you doing?
Oh, my God.
This is a lie.
This is actually a lie.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Let me...
Third person.
Everything looks a lot slower.
So much stuff is happening.
That, like...
I'm like...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay.
Here we go.
I have to use this, too.
Please.
I have to reload.
Jesus Christ.
Everything looks a lot slower, though, when I am third person.
That's for sure!
Jesus Christ.
What is... Reaper, how?
How?
Like, we're still fighting!
Just kill him!
Okay, no, third person is better.
Third person is better.
Oh my god.
I... I'm just saying, it is very difficult to keep track of what's going on when I'm first person.
I... I am struggling.
Like, when I was first person, it was so many things was going on.
I... Oh no, this is bad.
This is very bad.
I needed... I needed... Oh, this is bad for my Mercy.
That's so bad.
That was such a good ult.
We had nothing to counter.
We had nothing to counter that.
That's unlucky.
Oh my god.
No, I think their team was just better.
Their team was actually just better.
God, your Reaper's killing me.
He's a fuck.
Hey!
That's me!
I'm MVP!
I'm... I'm...
That's me!
I don't know how I got MVP, but I'll take it.
I'll...
Alright.
Yeah, I'll buy that.
I don't know how I'm doing it, but I take those.
Okay, I sold this so I can grab this.
And then, is that good?
Should I do anything else?
I got MVP, guys.
I think my team's bad.
I... I think... I think... I think maybe my team's bad.
I like how it's like...
I like how it's like... But it's wristbands, cause... He's right!
I looked it up!
Please have noted that this... Bro, they rulebooked the men!
He's getting rulebooked right now!
Oh my god!
Report!
He's getting rulebooked!
Hey, I got MVP, though.
Hey, guys.
I'm very important, guys.
Woo!
Very important person here!
That's me!
I'm very important, guys.
My teammates are struggling.
Oh my god!
He's exploiting on stream?!
That's...
Most val... Most very important person.
I keep... I forgot to use this.
Whoops!
Sorry!
Oopsie!
Oh... I need to use my... I need to do my key... left... the right click a lot better.
This soldier is just running!
Like... He's... He's just running!
I... I don't know!
Wait.
How do we let our... Orisa die like that?
Like... He's not even fighting!
He's just... Running!
He is actually just running!
He's not even fighting!
Bro, he's literally... I don't know what the fuck he was doing!
Okay.
You run.
Only one person needs to push it anyway.
I don't even remember that.
You're fast now!
You're fast!
Go!
Keep walking!
Oh my god!
Stop walking!
Why did you... Stop walking!
Okay, nice.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I am trying my best to keep him up.
My god, buddy.
Here we go.
Oh, I'm sorry, buddy.
I tried.
I'm trying my best to keep you up, buddy.
Number one!
What?
He has...
He gets another...
You can build it so you can have two walls?
Wow!
When did mom let you have two walls?
That's crazy!
Oh my god!
When did mom let you have two walls?
Every time?
Really?
Oh, so that's the bug!
Oh, I see.
I was like, how?
Wow!
That's what I'm saying!
Our soldier doesn't even... Our soldier's inting now!
He lives forever!
Forever.
He just lives forever.
That's crazy.
Yeah, but he's using the bug where he can... he doesn't need a TP to ult.
That's what they're saying.
He's doing it so that... and this other soldier is like throwing right now.
Except for when he does that.
Okay.
I don't know.
I just... you know like when you just don't trust your teammate?
That's me right now.
There we go.
Whoa!
I'm alive!
Please kill the soldier!
Guys!
Shotgun him!
It's not that hard to shotgun a soldier.
Wait, why?
Why?
Nice.
Shotgun... on the soldier.
I'm MVP again!
I don't know how.
I don't know what I'm doing.
But hey, I take those.
It's time for Clash!
How am I getting MVP?
What am I doing?
I don't... what am I doing to get MVP?
I don't know.
Alright, guys.
Should I try and buy more better abilities?
What can I buy?
What can I replace now?
Can I replace my blues?
What is my blues?
I'm gaming.
Go to the ability tab.
Yeah?
What do I replace on?
Buy more purples?
Yeah, but buy what though?
What do I buy?
The second blue one?
This one?
This one.
Nanocola.
Okay, something that's 20%.
Oh my god!
40% ability power!
That's right!
That says 4... that's more than 20!
That's...
That's... that's more than 20!
I see it.
I see the vision, guys.
20 is... 40 is more than 20.
This is the match point.
The team needs to pull together to stay in the fight.
3... 2... 1...
Why can I get another purple?
It's too late.
Alright, it's too late.
I already did it.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Um...
That's a lot.
I'll say it.
I need reload though.
Okay.
No!
He got me!
He got the 42!
I can barely see!
Okay, now I know my torpedoes can full heal.
And it does a lot of damage too.
A little bit...
Over there.
Okay, this is bad though.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, I got mine too!
He's just running!
Sir!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, that 4% is a lot.
That actually is a lot.
Sir, he's just running.
What do we do?
They're pushing forward.
Oh, I thought I could...
Oh, nice.
Nice interrupt.
Oh, that's bad.
He heals?
What does that do?
Okay, I'm very confused.
Like, what is that doing?
Like...
I'm so confused.
What is that doing?
He's like running and I see like heal range going around.
I'm like, what is that?
Is he like shielding his teammates with that?
Is that what he's trying to do?
I'm so confused.
Like, I need this guy to die.
I...
I actually...
No!
God damn it.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
I need it beyond my all...
Fuck.
Jesus Christ.
It's so much damage.
It's actually...
Oh my god.
It's just damage everyone!
Reaper is so hard to play against.
Okay.
Okay, our Reaper...
Alright.
Our Reaper needs to pick it up.
Like, I'm...
Get him!
Get this!
Just get this soldier out of here!
Yeah, their DPS output is...
To be fair, their Reaper was so strong.
So he could like...
Basically max out his damage.
Every time.
Yeah, you saw it.
Hey, that's...
Wait, who's that?
Hey, that's me!
What did I do?
Yay!
I did that!
I got it!
Best player!
I don't know how...
But I'll take it.
I don't know...
I did that!
You see that?
Play of the game!
Guys, go check out Stadium.
Exclamation point.
Overwatch, guys.
I mean, Stadium's fun.
It's just...
Unlucky that...
Our enemy Reaper...
Was...
Creating a raid boss build.
Wait, which one is the...
Okay, so what is the meta support players?
What are the meta support players for Stadium?
I lost, but...
Play of the game!
Hehehehe.
Missile, Juno?
Kiri and Juno?
Wait, okay.
So what makes Kiri broken?
I didn't get the win.
I think everybody...
Everybody starts off as Rookie.
Don't listen...
Don't listen to them!
Lucio goes crazy!
Hehehehe.
Oh, I think it's a Mercy build.
That she has, like, two reses.
Two Suzu's.
Explosive Kunai's.
Clones?
Mobility?
Okay, we'll try...
Let's try Kiri then.
No wonder...
Okay, no wonder I was, like...
Doing really well in this ELO.
I was like...
There's no way...
Like...
I was like...
I could tell what ELO this is.
Because I was like...
I...
There's no way I'm doing more damage than our Reaper.
As, like...
Juno during the beginning.
I'll try Kiri.
That's me!
I'm Kiri.
Alright, so...
What are the builds for Kiri?
Where did I go?
What should I build?
The most, like...
The strongest build for Kiri.
I don't know.
I forgot to aim as Kiriko though.
So, I...
This is gonna be, like...
A little bit of an issue.
The only issue is that...
Her aim is, like...
Not my best.
Okay, so...
Kiri and Mer...
Mate!
That's interesting.
Alright, which one?
Time for the teams to kill.
Do I use example builds?
Or do I build my own?
Which might not be as pretty.
Do I get two Suzu's right now?
Where would it be?
Bounce in our ally.
Is it this one?
Suzu?
This one right now?
Okay, we'll get two.
Alright, so...
What do we get?
What should our...
Uh...
Thing be then?
What should our main ones be?
Compensator.
Power...
Playbook.
We focus on weapon power.
Ability power.
First aid.
Weapon.
Attack speed.
Get as many greens as possible.
Do I use these?
Go weapon?
Get weapon power.
Okay.
And then what?
Do I do...
What else do I do?
Attack speed maybe?
Ability?
Ability power?
Weapon and ability.
Okay.
What about attack speed?
Is that important or no?
I'll get shield as well.
I feel like more heals might as well.
Or life steal.
Maybe?
Life steal.
Life steal is good.
Alright.
The armory is about to close.
Did I get everything I can?
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh!
Life steal is not worth it.
God damn it!
I should've got attack speed.
I did it!
No!
I should've got attack speed!
I was...
Guys!
You could've told me!
Why didn't you tell me?
Okay.
What?
Oh my god!
Okay, his DPS is better.
His DPS was stronger.
Oh my god, he headshot me.
That was crazy.
He actually headshot me.
I didn't realize he could do that.
I didn't realize he can headshot me there.
Alright, let's see.
Shift.
Oh my god, it's been so long since I played Kiri.
Here we go.
What are the X's?
Everything feels a little slow though on Kiri.
Get over here.
No!
I'm trying my best to heal you!
I can't even DPS because you're taking so much damage!
Get over there.
Get over there, Ryan!
Get over there!
There you go.
That's fucking right!
They're pushing the barricade.
Okay.
I have another- No!
I didn't have a Suzu!
I didn't have another Suzu!
I was gonna be like, don't worry.
I got another Suzu.
Worry.
I did it.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Oh my god, please.
I am working so hard keeping you alive.
I- I- I don't know- I don't know how much more I can do.
I- I- I don't know how much more I can do.
I- I don't know how much- I tried so hard to keep them up.
Wait, our Ash- Okay.
I was gonna speed that.
Oh, nice.
That's good.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We're- we're not okay, but don't worry.
We're not okay, but don't worry.
You're fine!
Seconds remaining.
Oh my god.
This- these X's, though, is like bothering me so much.
I don't like it.
Oh no, this is bad.
This is bad.
I don't have anything else.
Oh, don't!
Why is my DPS not doing as much as them?!
Why?!
I can't DPS because I have to heal!
It was a hard fight, but they lose this round.
No.
The thing is...
Oh, it's me.
I wonder why!
It's me.
Why am I MVP?!
Team!
Please!
Okay, what do I do in second round?
What do I do in second round, guys?
What?
Okay, I should get rid of the life steal.
Life steal was a mistake.
And then...
Should I get blue?
Should I start getting blue and get weapon of power?
Getting 10% attack speed for 3 seconds.
Weapon power.
It's a fierce competition.
Who will cave to the pressure?
And who will come out?
Uh...
Should I get attack speed?
More attack speed?
Or...
Ability power?
Uh...
Or 10% gain.
200% projectile speed.
Oh, I could get this.
I can grant them 10% move speed.
I guess I'll try this.
Right?
Get, like, attack speed and then...
More attack speed.
I don't know.
Guys, I'm trying to get my spreadsheet up, but I don't...
But it's not...
I'm not cooking correctly.
I...
My attack sheet...
I don't know what I'm doing with my attack...
My spreadsheet right now.
I...
I might not be cooking very correctly, guys.
Fine.
Juno, what are you doing?
It's fine.
Okay, there you go.
I had to use both to keep me and Ryan alive.
Okay.
Oh, I need to focus up.
Oh, I can't climb up that.
I thought I could.
No!
I tried so hard to keep you up!
I swear to God!
I swear to God.
Okay.
Nice.
That means I can DPS now.
Well, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm not okay!
No!
It's not fine!
Things are not fine!
I thought it was fine, but it ended up not being fine.
Time to try again.
I don't know where my Juno was.
Now I'm gonna...
I have no idea where my Juno was.
I just felt like it was me and the Ryan in the world.
It's okay, though.
Sometimes it do be like that.
Jeez.
I have to use double so my Ryan won't die.
It's okay, Ryan.
We're gonna do...
Okay.
Alright, let's kill her.
Oh, no.
No!
I thought we could get it.
I wanted to kill that one guy.
But it didn't work.
I wanted to see if we could both kill him.
I got baited.
I got baited by my Ryan.
I was like, we can do this right.
Me and you.
Our Ryan is our best player.
You're not gonna lie.
Alright.
What is it like to be able to DPS?
What is it like?
I have to keep my Ryan up all the time!
Why?
What?
I don't understand!
I shouldn't be MVP!
This is my second game!
Trying to figure out spreadsheets!
Alright.
What do we do after that?
Clones?
Okay.
What do we...
What do we get after that?
Guys.
You see, guys.
I need more than I can.
Just keep having MVP.
Clones are explosive kunai.
Okay.
Where is explosive kunai?
Increase, decrease.
I'll do...
Do my clones do stuff too?
Where is explosive kunai?
Where is it?
Oh, here you go!
Your third...
Okay, here you go.
Okay, there you go.
And then...
Let me see.
Weapon...
When you heal it, I need more healing.
My teammate is not doing okay.
I need...
My team needs...
My team needs more heals.
Uh...
My clones heal?
Wait, do they?
Oh, okay.
Let me sell it then.
Can I stop?
I can't sell it!
Oh, I didn't know!
20 seconds left until we kick this round off.
Ability power for more healing.
Okay.
I'm trying to find ability.
In there.
All right.
I don't know.
It's over.
I...
I got confused.
No!
There's a plus 20!
Guys, I got confused!
My head!
3...
2...
1...
Capture the objective!
All right.
Commit!
Guys, I don't know.
My teammates have been dying really, really fast.
I don't know if we can do that, guys.
I...
I would love to be like, I don't care about my teammates.
But...
It does not look so good for my team.
In general.
Okay, Juno.
Just stand there.
What?
Oh my god.
Like...
Okay.
Thank you.
That's all I wanted.
That's good.
That's fine.
Me and my Ryan.
Me and my Ryan is just doing whatever we can.
Just...
Yeah.
Okay, that's cool.
That's cool.
What's the...
She's doing her best.
She bought Doki Watch.
She...
Arjuno...
Arjuno spent money, okay?
She's doing it.
She at least spent money, alright?
Let's just let it...
Man, I would...
I'm sorry, sir.
I...
We escaped both by Suzu.
It's fine.
There we go.
Go in.
Go in!
Oh my god!
Alright, nice.
It's okay.
I swear, I'm mostly, like, I have to heal.
Like, I don't...
I'm not trying to, but I actually have to heal.
Because Arjuno's not healing our Ryan.
So I have to...
Oh, whoops.
Alright.
Okay.
That's okay.
Like, I wanted DPS, but I can't.
So I have to stop building DPS builds because of it.
What are you doing?
I'm here.
Okay, that's good.
We made him use that ult.
Um, Ryan, our teammates are...
Our teammates need help.
Ryan?
Ryan, might be a little...
Might be a little too over-cellless here.
Might be...
Oh, I couldn't do anything there.
It means my thing can't go past.
Why did I... Okay.
It means I can't go past the thing.
I can't... I... I'm tired.
I'm tired of being MVP.
Team, I'm so tired.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna do more heals because my teammate needs more help with the heal department.
So, let's get the 20%.
And then, sadly, I have to heal more, sadly.
10%, 35%.
Alright, let's see how much I can... We don't need attack speed.
Let's just...
The suffering from success.
Alright, surely my teammates will survive, right?
Oh, I should get purples.
I almost forgot about the purples.
Do I have enough money?
I should have enough.
Alright, I'll sell my last green.
Only 20 seconds left until we kick this round off.
And then...
20%, 25%, 10%, 15%.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, I'm just... I can't.
I just need to make sure my Ryan doesn't die.
Alright, I... I need to... I need to make sure.
I need to make sure.
Alright.
After this, we'll try... We'll do another Juno build.
Wait, Talisman healing is weapon power?
Why did everybody tell me to do it?
Okay.
Alright.
It wasn't...
Alright, so apparently...
It was not...
Alright.
Well, now I know.
Guys!
Shoot!
Okay.
That's fine.
Alright, I didn't realize...
Ability power was...
You're so lucky.
But who's gonna...
Wimp.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
Me and Ryan against the world!
Me and Ryan!
I had to just heal.
All I did was just make sure...
Alright.
Okay, now that I know, Talisman is weapon power.
My Ryan and I... is just my Ryan and I.
I... You're welcome.
You're welcome.
Alright, me and Ryan against the world.
Okay.
Yet again.
Let's go, you and I.
You and I against the world.
Let's go.
They don't know.
You and I against the world, Ryan!
It's you and I!
My...
I can't DPS because it's just you and I, right?
Wish I could!
Wish I could shoot my gun, but it's just you and I, right?
We're against the world!
Wonder what it's like!
Wish I know what it's like!
I'm gonna shoot my gun!
There we go.
Okay, cat.
We had a rotten shield.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
It's fine.
Dude, I'm just... it's like... keep Ryan alive.
Look, he has 8k damage!
How much more does our Ryan have to do?
He actually has 8k.
Oh my god.
I... okay.
I need to know.
Finally!
Our Ryan has finally got MVP!
Guys, I need to know.
Do I do weapon power or do I do ability power?
Which is weapon power in my heals?
Because then I will redo all my...
Alright.
There is hope.
Because I will re- re-evaluate... myself.
Okay.
Weapon power.
I will sell...
I'm gonna sell this...
And then get weapon power.
Plus 20% up...
Weapon... 25!
There we go!
25...
Percent...
Weapon power.
There we go!
That's a lot more!
That is a lot!
Okay, and then I can...
Okay, let me put more on weapon power then.
5%, 10%, 20%, 10%.
I'll get less that.
And then put...
On...
We're in the middle innings and everyone's waiting to see...
Do you see the scaling?
What do you mean?
I'm gonna steal your build.
I'm...
Okay.
Oh, he has that.
Fantasmic.
The teams have 20 seconds left to turn around the round.
Okay.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Uh...
I'll put more weapon power.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
That should be more heals now.
It's not stealing.
It's mirror match.
Yeah!
I'll mirror match you.
I couldn't steal this build in time.
Okay, how do I use my clones?
Okay, so when do my clones show up?
Guys, how do I steal...
So how do I...
When I teleport?
Oh, when I teleport.
Okay.
Okay, that makes sense, actually.
Don't worry!
TP!
There's two of us!
What can you do now?
There you go!
There's two of us!
Protect the Rhyme!
Win the game!
Save the Rhyme!
Save the game!
Tootie, two of me!
Oh my god, this is actually the strat.
Here we go.
Don't worry!
I have to reload, but don't worry!
Know what I'll do?
Two of me!
I might have wasted that, but that's okay.
There's two of me though!
There's two of me!
I had to do that so I can...
I had to TP so there's two of me!
Okay, we need to get your cooldown reduction for it.
I'll do that.
One, she's second to none!
Oh my god!
This is bronze, you know.
I'll heal myself.
The Rhyme's still alive, you're right!
You're right, the Rhyme...
I don't like the X that shows up on my screen.
I don't even know that I missed.
Like, that I would...
Not missed, but I don't even know that I can't hit that.
Like, I think that's like useless info.
Okay.
That's fine.
Soldier, I need to know what are you doing.
What?
Help him!
Why is that bob so tiny?
Why?
Why is that such a tiny bob?
Don't worry!
There's two of me now!
Oh my god!
That out heals...
That does not heal me.
That...
He's average size.
What do you mean?
I'm just gonna say...
The Rhyme did as much as he could.
The Rhyme...
Did so much.
What do you mean?
No DPS intake!
Our Rhyme was actually like...
The best player!
Our Rhyme...
Our Rhyme did so much for us!
The Rhyme check!
Of course they say that!
Bro!
What do you mean?
Alright, let's do another Juno.
We'll do another Juno and I wanna try an Ana build.
The least delusional Juno!
I literally saw a Rhyme and did everything!
I...
I don't know how I did...
I can't believe blame their tank!
Here's the bathroom right back.
And I'm back.
I'm having fun with Stadium though.
I think Stadium is very interesting because it feels...
Faster.
It's a lot faster than...
Um...
Uh...
Than...
Um...
Regular matches.
And like...
It definitely feels like it could turn around.
Yeah, the builds are interesting.
I...
I agree.
Alright.
It's time to practice.
Alright, so...
What do I...
Do I just get...
Do I just follow this entire build?
Alright, what do I build?
What is the best build for Juno?
I...
I tried to...
I think I...
What was the other build?
Okay, so what do we do?
Guide me.
What is like the most...
The strongest build you can do for Juno?
Just ability max?
Like, what do I do?
All ability power?
So...
Ability power.
Ability...
Cooldown redu...
Okay, where's cooldown reduction?
Cooldown reduction...
Where would that be?
Bottom, middle, blue, inability...
This one?
Which one?
The rare, yellow...
This one?
Lock on shield?
So we got this.
Which one's the cooldown reduction?
Which one does...
Which one's cooldown reduction, guys?
Reduction, ironize...
Oh my god, there's so much thing.
Middle, right?
Well...
Oh, there you go.
Cooldown reduction.
Okay, so...
Okay...
This says cooldown reduction...
Cooldown reduction...
5%, 15%.
Okay...
How strong is this?
I understand...
Holy...
Okay, that's a lot of damage.
That's a lot.
Okay, so when I start off...
Jesus...
Oh my god...
Okay...
Alright...
So if I do...
Oh, I got 4 tributes.
Do I get 4 tributes?
Okay, so...
Where it is...
Alright, so...
If I...
Don't have...
The...
Okay, so...
I'm clearly...
I'm spamming these.
Okay, so I need to get yellow.
And then...
God, this is like a spreadsheet.
Okay, ability power...
Do I need lifesteal?
Or...
Does it matter?
Do I just focus on ability power?
Cause like...
What do I...
Should I just focus all on ability power then?
Or...
Should I...
No lifesteal?
Lifesteal?
It doesn't matter?
Okay, so...
Overheal ability...
No lifesteal.
Okay, so...
When we start off round 1...
How much money do you get for round 1?
I can't afford that.
3.5k?
Okay, so...
I can't afford...
Okay, not enough for the yellow.
So what do we...
Buy...
What do we buy then?
We got armor?
We should...
Ability power and...
Cooldown reduction.
Okay, cooldown reduction.
Where is cooldown reduction?
3,000.
Do we have...
I don't think we can afford cooldown reduction though.
Yeah, but like...
Starting off...
We don't...
We can't afford cooldown reduction.
Attack speed and weapon power.
Okay, so...
We can just do...
This and this.
So then we have that.
And then we'll start out with these three.
And then...
After...
Okay, so we'll start out with attack power and weapon power and...
Alright.
Let's start with that.
Holy shit.
This gets complicated.
I'm...
This is like...
It's like MOBA...
Like I said, it's like a MOBA and hero shooter.
So it gets like...
Complicated.
I get in first cause I...
Cause I'm on an SSD.
I have a better PC.
So I get to pick first.
I think...
I'm pretty sure in Rookie Lobby, I would be the only person with the best PC in...
I feel like...
In these Rookie Lobbies, I'd definitely be the...
One person with the best PC in my team.
Wait, chat.
Um...
I play video games for a living.
Alright.
So...
We'll go with attack speed.
Uh...
And...
Attack power.
What was it?
Ability power.
Okay.
They have Mora.
That's good.
I'm on meta.
I play meta.
Alright.
Then we'll do...
Torpedo.
Charge.
Ability power.
These three.
Okay.
And then after that...
Alright.
Let's talk about...
Next one.
So we focus on...
Ability power.
After that.
So we'll do 10%.
When aiming game.
Overheal.
So we do...
Wait.
We'll do...
Should we focus on...
We'll get the yellow.
After.
And then we'll sell...
For the yellow.
We'll get the yellow.
And then...
Focus on ability power here.
Yeah.
Round two.
Yellow.
Alright guys.
We're thinking.
Guys.
Multi-tool.
What the heck is multi-tool?
Multi-tool?
What's multi-tool?
Guys.
Where is...
You gotta be like...
Blue middle.
Blue...
First line...
First row...
Middle.
Or something.
Ha ha ha ha.
Yeah.
You gotta be specific.
Green.
Middle.
Row.
Two.
Or something.
Ha ha ha ha.
You can't...
You can't be like...
Multi-tool.
Ha ha ha.
Middle.
Right.
And the blue.
Okay.
Middle.
Right.
And up.
There you go.
Middle.
Left.
Right.
Middle.
There you go.
You just suck my battleship.
Okay.
Blue middle.
Row.
Right.
Kick.
I need to be more like in the air as Juno.
It's been a while since I played Juno in general.
Phew.
Alright.
I hope...
Okay good.
I was gonna say it.
Okay.
You gotta win.
That's fine.
Does this help?
Oh my god.
This is not fair.
He has a shield.
That's not fair.
There.
Oh no.
No.
I want to get that escape.
Oh.
Could he get pissed?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Hello everybody.
Hi.
Dr. Nick.
I'm gonna grab my E too.
There.
I'm using more as a DPS.
What?
How?
What was that?
What the?
What was that damage?
Nice.
Oh my god.
What are you doing?
Oh, he's so low.
I'm sad.
I almost got her too.
I'm a little scared here.
Alright.
Hey, I got damage on the shield though.
Oh.
No.
Okay.
No way!
It got me!
I was so far.
It curved?
How did it curve?
Oh, she went forward.
That's how she curved.
She- I was like, how did it curve?
Oh, she just like walked to it like that.
Okay.
Yeah, I was gonna say that should kill him.
Nice.
Go.
Go fast.
He's so low.
Please.
Oh my god.
Go in there.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
they just have better builds!
What can I say?
No!
I'm getting- I'm trying to get healed as much as I can from this but it's very difficult because there is a lot of damage.
Oh my god.
There is so much damage.
Jesus, I don't know how I'm alive but here I am.
I'm trying my best with the team I have.
I bought so much time.
I'm just bending the beans.
I bought time though.
That was, you know, it was a good effort.
I did my best.
I did what I could.
Alright, so lock on shield.
And then we get multi-tool.
Okay, we can afford multi-tool.
That's good.
Okay, so now we should be a little stronger now.
At least not MVP.
I hope not.
I feel like, oh my god, it would be very embarrassing after that.
So I got 12k money?
Was that what I got?
Wait, is this?
Is this like the amount of money we got?
In general?
From playing?
So our Ash got more money, right?
Oh, okay.
So our Mercy got the least.
Okay.
That's right, you better be sorry.
Whack.
You better be sorry.
Alright, at least I know I'm doing my job, guys.
I'm doing my job, at least.
I'm doing all I could.
It's not mean, I'm motivating.
I think not being able to change heroes is a little scary, though.
Because it's like...
I don't know, like...
You can't do counterplays.
But I guess, like, the ability is the counterplay?
Is that it?
I assume, like, the ability is counterplay, right?
Also, what the heck is this lab?
A lot of stuff is scary.
That's right, run.
Okay, Mercy, I saw that.
I saw that, Mercy.
I saw that.
Mercy, I saw that, Mercy.
Oh my god.
That Mercy shot the reflecting bullets.
I...
I saw her shoot the reflecting bullets, guys.
I saw it.
And unfortunately, I had to witness it.
Doink.
Okay.
Where are they going?
I shouldn't have wasted that, but, like, I got curious.
Where's my cast?
I was like...
Where is he?
Like...
I'm a little confused.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh!
No!
Why are you always chasing me?
Why...
Why are you always trying to chase me?
Get away from me!
There we go.
I'm good.
I'm okay.
You know what?
That more rents straight at me, Whiffer.
Whiffer.
Whiffer, oh, I'm so sad.
Alright, that's good.
At least... at least, like, my team is actually being good teammates.
Okay, now... now I have to think.
Now I have to figure this out.
Okay, if I sell... okay, one, two, three, and then I'll have 9,000.
That's not enough, though, for any of the... I have to get an ability... I guess I can get this one for now.
I'll get more ability power.
Yeah, I'll put this, and then I'll sell this and my greens for 40% ability power.
Did the power coolant?
Wait.
Get the power?
Wait, which one's that?
Weapon.
It's in.
Oh, I forgot to... oh, sorry.
Um.
Get the... which one is it?
Power coolant cosmic.
Uh, what do I get?
Which one do I get, guys?
Guys, which one do I get?
I have 35 seconds.
Second to last on the right.
This one caught...
Cosmic coolant?
Cooldown is reduced.
Okay.
Look at that.
Cosmic coolant.
Let's go.
Yay!
20 seconds to go.
All right.
Okay, we got this.
We got this, guys.
We're one to one.
We figured it out.
We're building.
We're building!
We've built...
We have our spreadsheets!
And the arrows and the diagrams!
All right.
Here we go.
Wait.
Did I go the wrong way?
Whoops.
My bad.
I don't know if I went the wrong way or not.
Oh my god.
Cass, please.
That was scary.
But it's okay.
My team's okay.
Oh, it reflects.
Go take that speed!
Be fast!
Okay, nice.
Nice, we got mercy.
Nice.
What is he gonna do?
Nothing!
Oh, wait.
What is our...
Don't worry.
I got you.
I got you!
That's right.
You can't bend this now!
Ow.
No!
Live.
Oh my god, I need...
Please.
Mercy.
I'm right here.
Nice, we got it.
No!
The moment I said that, I...
I'm sad.
I'm...
I'm so sad.
I'm from downtown with the steel chair.
I...
He came out of nowhere with a steel chair.
It's not fair.
Okay, I should've waited a little bit.
The steel chair out of nowhere.
Okay, nice.
All right, that should be enough heals.
I'm gonna save my ult for now.
Because I don't think we need it.
There you go.
Oh, that Genji was low.
That's fine.
I'll just use this for heals.
I'll use this.
Oh, that's good!
That's a huge ult!
Oh no.
Oh no!
They said use everything, but it's too late!
We got it!
Oh!
Thank God!
Thank God we have actual DPS!
I'm so happy.
We have real DPS player.
Our Ashe is actually carrying.
All right, so we have 8,000.
So I can get rid of ability power.
And then I...
Okay, so I wanna buy...
Which one was it?
It was like super strong.
Oh, this one.
13,000.
Okay, I could get rid of...
Here, attack speed.
So I can afford...
Oh wait.
Oh, I still can't afford it.
Oh my God.
I still can't afford it.
Okay.
Um...
If I get...
I could buy it.
I already have Nanocola.
What else can I get?
50 shields.
15 percent.
I could get this one.
Oh, get rid of Nanocola?
Okay, and then...
Oh, I could get that.
Yeah, you're right.
And then I'll just put back this.
And then...
Only 20 seconds left.
Uh...
And I'll...
I'll keep back these two.
All right, here we go.
All right.
Now we should have more ability power.
That should be fine.
There you go.
Now we have 40 percent.
And then like...
If we can afford...
We afford the 20 percent.
Oh, I...
Oops.
I messed up.
It's okay.
We'll do it later.
We'll have...
We'll use it here, guys.
It's okay.
Whoops.
It does that countdown in my head.
I feel like it happened.
You know?
You know when like...
The countdown happens.
And so you think like...
It's already happened.
Okay.
Nice.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I need you to stop standing there though.
But I got you.
Oh my god.
The ability power is working, guys.
It's working, guys.
The ability power.
Oh my god.
I'm ability power-y.
Okay, Mercy.
I see that.
I...
Oh, they dodged that.
That was a good dodge.
Okay.
That's on you.
That's on you too.
I...
I don't know what I can do there.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'm on it.
No!
Are you serious?
I went on it for us!
I did it for us!
Can I even...
No, I can't.
I'm so sad.
I did all of that too.
Like, I don't know what else I could do.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
Nice.
Oh.
Come on.
She's so low.
Kill her.
Yes!
Oh my god.
I did it.
Do it for her.
Mercy!
I just...
Okay.
You know what?
It's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Oh, wait.
I have more money than our other DPS.
Let's go.
You know what?
I think I'm doing my part.
Mercy, please.
I think I'm doing my part, guys.
I think I'm playing as well as I can.
Uh...
Alright.
A bit...
Okay, we're counting 5,000.
Wait.
I can afford that.
Okay.
We get rid of...
10 per...
Okay.
We keep that.
Get rid of weapon power.
And then...
Put it on...
Nanocola.
And then...
Is there any more ability power I should get?
Okay.
That's 20%.
We should...
Oh, don't forget.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
Medicinal missiles.
Okay.
Alright.
And then healing torpedoes.
Okay.
Uh...
What else can I get?
What else?
Is this a good build?
I'm Nanocola.
I have 5%.
Should I get rid of attack speed or should I keep it, guys?
If I get rid of attack speed, I can build...
Wait.
I can get...
No.
I can get rid of this and get that.
And then I get 5% ability power and 10%.
And 10% attack speed.
Or I could get more ability...
Okay, 10%.
I could get this one.
Hyper ring.
Or...
Or I could get...
Actually, 5%.
Or do I do this one?
Or do I do custom stock?
Should I do wrist wraps, lux loop, or custom shock?
Or stock?
Which one do I get?
Lux loop or...
No, keep the...
Oh, keep the attack speed?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go.
Guys, I'm think...
I'm...
I...
I'm almost thinking.
Okay.
Guys, guys, guys.
I'm cooking now.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I keep doing it.
It's just reflex, guys.
I swear to God.
It's reflex.
I can't help it.
I can't help it, guys.
I actually can't help it.
Okay, here.
It's just like in my nature.
It's in my nature to hear a countdown and then press my buttons.
If they did want me to do anything, then they shouldn't have given me a countdown.
That's all I'm saying.
That's on them for giving me a countdown.
Oh, I'm lucky.
I want it.
Oh, my God.
What the...
Mercy, please.
I'm so resable.
Oh, my God.
That...
I need to remember, like, the shit that he can do.
I...
What the heck is the damage?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Why?
Okay.
The damage for that is crazy.
That's my bad.
That...
That ride...
Okay.
Now I'm, like, ego peeking the ride because I didn't think he'd be that strong.
The ride's ability power.
That's right.
Run.
Okay.
That ride's ability power is actually crazy.
What?
Where?
Okay.
I need to see this.
I didn't even see...
Oh, my God.
He had peeker's advantage.
He actually had third-person peeker advantage.
Because I was, like, where did that come from?
The goddamn peeker's advantage.
That's what...
I would say I am not performing as...
Okay.
I mean, I might as well.
It doesn't overlay.
My ability power is so strong.
Yeah!
That's right.
Ability power!
Wait.
I got second.
Nice.
I was, um...
Second best player.
Wait, no.
Actually, no.
I was third best player.
Never mind.
I saw our...
Our, uh...
What's his name?
I forgot her name.
Slashy Slash.
Our Ashe was so good, though.
I was better than one of our DPS.
I didn't.
All right.
Okay, so...
Oh, nice.
I got...
Uh...
125 of them.
Oh, they have...
Junker Queen.
Yeah.
Okay, I want to do...
Okay.
What is...
Okay, I was getting clapped because I was egoing to Rhyne so hard.
I...
I will admit...
I may or may not have been egoing to Rhyne.
Because I didn't realize how strong Rhyne can be at the final round.
He was also doing ability power.
His ability power was unfortunately stronger than what my HP was.
I literally looked at him and then I was gone.
Okay.
Now I understand why people were saying Juno was scared in...
In...
Stadium.
All right.
Okay.
What does Deanna build?
Is Deanna strong?
Guys.
Is Deanna a good build or no?
Is Deanna a good build chat?
Or is she like...
Like a throw pick?
Is she a throw pick or is she actually good?
Hehehehe.
Sometimes rough to use?
Okay.
What...
Should we try Kiriko again then?
All right.
What build do we do?
AOE and Nano is strong?
Okay.
But what is that?
Oh, is it...
That's...
Is it our turn?
She just dies.
Oh.
That doesn't sound fun.
Thank you for sh...
First chatter.
That...
That sounds pretty miserable.
I...
Maybe we don't play on.
Good prank.
But might be good.
Okay.
She sounds fun!
All right.
Oh.
All right, guys.
Do we do Ana or do we try...
Go for the challenge.
Do we...
Go try Ana.
Do we throw or do we go Kiriko?
Guys, do we throw or do we go Kiriko, guys?
Here's the thing.
Throw.
Okay.
Let's try.
All right, guys.
Yeah.
Oh, so I have my London Spitfire skin.
I love London Spitfire.
London Spitfire was one of my favorite teams in Overwatch League.
All right.
Okay, so what do we do for the Ana build?
What is it?
Yeah, they were one of my favorites.
I think it was like...
It was London Spitfire and...
Uh...
Soul Dynasty.
London Spitfire, Soul Dynasty, and...
Yeah.
These two are my favorite teams.
Look at these teams.
Oh, hey.
They're more meta than...
Oh, wait.
They're...
Guys, I think the enemy team is going meta.
All right.
So what do we do?
It's time for the teams to consult their playbooks.
What do we buy for power?
And what do we focus on, chat?
Do we focus on ability power?
What do we focus on?
These are example builds picked by the pros to start our competitors off on the right foot.
Power?
Okay, we focus on power.
5% weapon power.
Ability power?
I mean, we can buy both.
Um...
And then what?
Okay, what about the top?
What do we get for the top?
For power.
What do we get?
Need ability power.
Okay.
Nano Boost, Nano Boost, Sleep Dart.
Is it this one?
Grants Overheal?
Oh, crit?
Which one is it?
Guys, we have 40...
Give me...
There's names on them!
There's your full potential!
Nano Boost, Home Remedy!
Sleep Dart, my turn!
Our turn!
Tactical Rifle!
Pinpoint!
Home Remedy?
That one...
Guys, names!
Home Remedy!
Which one?
16!
I don't know!
You're...
You're supposed to help me!
Um...
Home Remedy.
Okay.
Um...
Did Lifesteal?
I don't...
I don't know.
I was freaking out.
I was panicking.
Oh.
They knew I was...
I was panicking.
We don't play...
Guys, we had a full minute!
We knew our plan!
What do I do?
Do I just give us Overheal right now?
The objective unlocks in 10 seconds.
Don't worry.
Overheal!
What the heck?
Oh my god.
It's been...
Okay, um...
Third Person Ana might not be it for me, though.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
What is that for looking at?
What is this boulder?
Okay, that boulder is crazy.
Oh, it's so weird.
Okay, it's really weird.
I'm not used to it.
I am not used to it at all.
I'm not used to Third Person.
I am...
I am not used to Third Person Ana.
I think it's the scope.
It's the scope part.
I'm not used to.
Please!
I'm right behind you!
Where's my Mora?
Where?
Where is my Mora?
Where did my Mora go?
All right.
Just say...
No, it's because when...
It throws me off when I do Third Person.
And then...
I scope in.
So I get...
I get, like, so thrown off from it.
That was, like, my...
That's my only issue.
Oh, that's unlucky.
It's fine.
Waste of name.
I believe.
Go in.
There we go.
I got overheal for us.
I don't believe in us, but it's okay.
I have spirit.
How about you?
No!
I need...
I was waiting for my nade!
I have to wait for my nade!
Okay, now I understand why, like...
I'm a glass cannon.
I understand now.
I understand what you mean when you say it.
Doki, you'd be a glass cannon.
Alright.
But...
I'm not the worst player.
I am the second best player.
That's all that matters.
Alright.
Okay, now what do we...
Okay, we focus on...
We...
Ability power, right?
So...
We focus on...
Do we focus on ability power?
Or...
Weapon power?
Ability power.
Okay, so we focus on ability power.
And let me...
5% ability.
I can do...
I'll do nanocola.
Okay.
I'll do nanocola then.
And then I can get...
We've already seen so much action.
I'll get rid of...
I don't know.
I feel like the...
I don't know why I should get...
Get cooldown reduction?
Okay.
Cooldown reduction.
Do we have cooldown reduction?
Turning ultimate...
Ability.
Cooldown.
I don't know why I should do lifesteal.
I don't think it's as good.
Or...
Oh!
Actually, no.
I don't care about my team enough for that.
Oh no.
I'll just keep lifesteals for now.
Put that in.
I have enough for that.
Alright.
I'll keep my lifesteal just for now.
I don't know what...
I don't know what I'm doing.
What?
Look at my cool spray.
Look at that.
It moves.
Alright.
I don't know...
I don't know where cooldown reduction is, guys.
I want to play first person for Ana only because...
I want to do it only because that...
Only because it's...
Only because, like...
It's so chaotic.
Yeah.
I don't like swapping.
It's just too chaotic for me to do first person.
I don't like this part.
That's why I'm like...
I want to do first person because I don't like the...
Like that...
What?
How did you guys die?
I do use overnade there.
Please!
Mora!
My Mora never heals me!
I'm so sad!
Mora!
I swear to you!
Why don't you heal me?
Sad.
I'll kill you myself, I guess.
I'm sad.
The Mora never heals me.
She hates me.
She hates us.
Is this Juno?
Likes to...
Likes to front...
Uh...
Likes to flank.
Which I've noticed.
I need cooldown reduction for this though, for sure.
I need to use the overheal.
Oh, he...
Okay, I didn't think he was gonna look that way.
Where's our tank going?
Pink, where are you going?
Pink.
Pink!
Pink?
Okay.
Pink, where you go?
I don't know what my tank was doing.
Oh my god.
Me and Mora are like...
Have more points than our tank and other DPS.
Alright guys, Ana...
I think it's a long Kong build.
For sure.
Go in, please.
Please, go in.
Why are you scared?
WHY ARE YOU SCARED?
Coming up next, it's time for Clash.
Oh my god, don't be scared!
Now's the time for our teams to work out their strategies.
Okay, what do we do for power?
Power and then let's figure out how to be better.
Alright, cooldown reduction.
Cooldown... I'm trying to find...
Alright, I'm gonna figure it out for power and then I'm gonna try to find a cooldown reduction.
Where the heck is cooldown reduction?
Cooldown...
Reduces cooldown, landing a sleep dart affected by the 5k middle right.
Oh, there it is, okay.
Alright.
Alright, power.
What do we do?
Our turn?
Also affects other allies.
It has... okay.
So everybody gets a nano.
Yeah.
Okay, so...
We have that.
Okay, let's see if I can get more.
10%.
I wanna get rid of this, but...
I don't know if I can have anything else.
That would be good.
I don't have enough money for...
Let's see.
You can spend your ultimate after you spend...
Oh!
Okay, there you go.
We should get that.
So then...
After I spend my ultimate, I don't need life steal.
I can just have more ability power after all.
Okay.
This should be okay now.
Alright, after this, we'll try Mora.
Get my beautiful boy.
Wanna see the sunset to get their dragoons?
Whoa!
Only top 500 players allowed though.
If you're not top 500, close your eyes.
I'll just use my overheal here.
I'll just give everybody overheal.
I assume that's the strat.
Okay, that's on you.
I have to reload.
That's on you.
I wanna use it...
Okay, guys.
There is a soldier that's just there.
Oh!
Okay, our...
I don't know.
I feel like Orisa is like...
So scared for no reason.
I don't know why.
Orisa is so scared.
I'm gonna take high ground here.
And then we let a soldier just walk.
Like I...
Oh no.
I wanted to...
I see you.
Where are they?
I can't nade that.
Oh no.
Unlucky.
I got to sleep though.
No!
Okay, that's a little too late though.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Tee, please!
That's the worst part.
I think Ana...
I can see why Ana is difficult.
In this elo.
Ana is definitely...
Oh, it's definitely in this...
Uh...
Oh my
god.
AHHHHH!
Looks like the wind...
The score is...
I'm trying!
2-0.
You can really tell who the playmakers are.
Alright, I'll try a first person.
I'm gonna try first person.
I just feel like disoriented when I have to just scope.
My Morha...
Gave up.
Alright.
I have $7,000.
Do I... Can I buy...
I guess I could sell...
If I sell...
Nano.
And then...
One of...
I'll sell this so I can buy this.
So I have 40%...
Ability power.
That you just died.
Yeah, I'm...
I'm finding out that...
Ana...
I need a team to play Ana.
I need a team to like actually...
I can enable...
To be able to play Ana.
I don't think I'm getting enabled much.
I don't think I'm...
I'm enabling much.
Alright, let's try a first person.
Okay.
Is 70 to default?
Oh yeah, 70.
Okay, first person.
Video.
Okay, I have it maxed, okay.
Just so zoomed in after third person.
I can't grenade often though, that's the thing.
It's the match point.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, I just get so overwhelmed in first person for stadium.
It's like...
So difficult to...
Okay, Mercy player.
Like, how could it be more fun?
Oh my god, so...
There we go.
Please!
More!
Oh!
Okay.
It's okay.
It's okay, I'm fine.
Get over here right now.
You need it.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm trying my best to keep you up.
Please!
More!
I saw the right
click!
I...
I'm falling right click!
Instead of healing me!
I'm so messed up!
So messed up.
Oh my god.
Who told me to play higher?
I'm not feeling it.
Oh, I missed that too.
Guys, I'm... I may or may not... I'm being affected right now.
Guys, I'm not getting healed.
It's not fun when you're not getting healed, guys.
That boulder shit is actually crazy.
Oh, I thought he was gonna... Sorry, that was my bad.
Sorry, that was my bad.
Um... You got this.
Whoops.
I should have ulted that.
That was a throw.
I... Okay.
Okay, this entire... That round, that's on me.
I messed up on the nade and the ult.
I would omit... I threw that part.
That fight.
I would omit that.
Please.
Get the overheal going in.
Please, get the overheal going in.
I would... Oh... I understand now.
I...
I understand now.
Guys, I understand now.
I like looked at it, and I was like, oh, that's where my moro was.
Is that... I am .
If I... I...
I...
Armora was not playing the game.
It was... It was mostly... Okay.
Also, like, Armora was, like, AFK.
Like, I think half of the game.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, I get it.
Also, I'm not playing Ana in Stadium.
I think I'll only play Ana in Stadium if I actually have a team.
If I have a team, then I'll... I'll play Ana.
In this elo, in Peslo, Ana's not it.
It just wasn't it for me.
Alright, let's do a Mora build.
Not at all.
Doing builds is so complicated, though.
Alright.
Okay.
What is the... What are the builds?
What do you focus on for Mora?
Ability power?
Everything is just ability power.
I guess lifesteal, right?
Because...
I feel like if you're always using ability, you're always having lifesteal.
Alright.
What else?
I guess weapon power.
Double orb for me.
Okay.
After using...
You spend...
Okay, this one.
Full damage?
Okay.
So you do damage and ability power.
You do damage and ability power.
Just because, like, you got the...
Uh...
Multi...
Okay.
First up, who's ready to stop the push?
Alright, let's see.
Yay!
First pick!
I think after playing all these characters for support...
I think my favorite so far...
Has to be...
Has to be Juno.
I think Juno...
Juno was the...
Was the most fun...
In the stadium.
Out of all the characters I tried out today.
I think Blackwatch is my favorite skin.
What the...
Sorry, I'm trying...
Ability power Juno is fun.
Okay, so...
Multi-ball.
Start with multi-ball.
And then...
What do you guys say?
The cosmic...
Um...
Alright, so...
Ability power...
Weapon power...
And what else do we do?
What else do we do?
Uh...
Survival...
Gain...
Ability...
Lifesteal...
Do we do lifesteal?
Or do we...
Ten...
Do we do...
Oh, crossword?
What is crossword?
Do we look at...
Ten percent weapon...
Attack speed?
Or ten percent weapon lifesteal?
Is attack speed better?
Okay, attack speed.
Okay.
More suck.
Alright.
Let me know...
What else to do...
In round two.
Let me know what to do for round two after.
Oh, wait.
We have an Ana also.
Oh, this Ana...
Oh, this Ana's not gonna have a good time.
Oh, no.
I am the...
I am Annie now.
It's my turn.
This Ana will have a Mora, right?
Um...
We'll see...
How does that...
Oh, my God.
That's the multi-bolt?
What?
Me?
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha.
Okay.
Why heal when I can DPS?
That's right.
Oh, no.
That's not right.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh.
There you go.
Yay!
Ha, ha, ha.
Nice.
Wait, that's easy.
Now I know what has...
Oh, my God.
Mora's so easy in Pistdo.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha.
Alright.
Be super aggressive.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing right now.
Okay.
Also, now I know.
I was like...
Oh, my God.
Now I...
Alright.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Suck!
Nice.
I understand now.
They can't aim.
Yay!
We did it!
Alright.
That explains why my Mora did not need to heal anybody.
I see now.
Alright, I'm getting life steal.
I'm getting life steal.
Actually, is there a better life steal?
5% weapon power.
Alright, what do we get, actually?
We get 10% ability power and 10% life steal.
And then we'll get cooldown so we can have multiple orbs.
And...
Well, we can't... we don't have enough for...
Uh, multi-shot.
Yeah, I got multi-tool.
We... multi-shot?
What's multi-shot?
Okay, so I think that should be good.
Alright, can I steal anybody's builds?
What?
No weapon life steal?
Did I not buy life steal?
Oh, okay.
Um... I mean, I could buy... I'll buy weapon life steal... too.
So then... yeah, there you go.
Armory is about to close.
Alright.
I don't think we need attack speed.
I'm gonna do...
Alright, here we go.
I can have life steal, too.
I can live forever now.
Our Ana doesn't need heals.
She didn't... she doesn't have... she doesn't have anyone diving here, so she'll be fine.
I believe in her.
I believe in her because she didn't... she seemed like she's okay.
The objective unlocks in 10 seconds.
They don't have a D.Va, too, which is great.
That's right.
Suck!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
No!
Yeah!
I did a thousand damage after that.
I...
Nice.
I'm Piranha.
I'm not...
I am that person now.
I am them.
Alright, I'll throw in an...
I'll throw in an...
No, actually, no.
They don't need heals.
Ha ha ha ha!
It's all about that DPS, baby.
Okay, I'll heal her.
Just a little bit.
They don't need it.
Guys, they don't need it.
I have this.
See?
Look at that.
Look.
They're all okay.
Don't worry.
I'm healing my guy.
They're fine.
See?
Look at that.
There you go.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Okay, this...
Nevermind.
Moro's more fun.
Moro's fun in this elo.
Ha ha ha.
No.
Moro is definitely more fun in this elo.
I will say that, when they can't aim, this elo is...
We have love not aiming.
It's just like the old days.
This!
So back.
Alright, what do we do for power?
What is good for power?
When you just fade, spawn a stationary...
Well, I want a DPS.
I want a...
Okay, our Ana was not getting dived non-stop.
Okay.
Cross?
Cross orbital?
Cross, okay.
Alright, and then...
Let us focus on...
I want to do weapon.
Or ability power.
Okay, we could...
How much do I have?
We could buy nano cola.
And then...
I have 5% weapon power.
But I want more weapon power.
So I could sell...
I can't...
I can't afford it.
Okay, uh...
I was gonna buy this, but I don't have enough.
10%, 5% ability power.
I want to do more damage, but I don't think I can.
If I sell these two, I still don't have enough money for this.
Unless I sell this, but...
This is good.
Yeah.
I'll use this for now.
Bottom, row, middle, rare, ability?
This one?
Or this one?
Well, I can't afford it yet.
I'll save.
Okay.
But I'm getting the kills.
Yay!
Woo!
I have strong ability power though.
Jesus.
Okay.
That was scary.
Oh, that sucks.
I couldn't mute myself.
Forward, Akko.
Akko, forward!
Forward, Akko!
Oh, I should have healed.
That's fine.
Not fine.
Nice.
That's fine.
I suck!
Suck!
Sucky suck!
Whoa!
Yeah!
Suck!
Oh, unfortunate for him.
That's fine.
Oh, I should heal.
I should really heal.
It's okay.
I can still throw this out.
Suck time.
Suck power.
Oh, no.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
That's not fair.
He counter-ulted me.
I can't believe it counter-playing my Overwatch too.
Okay, I should start dealing.
Nice, I'm okay.
C'mon, die!
Die!
Oh.
That's a lucky.
But I have good attack though.
Oh my god, okay, I... Okay, nice.
Oh, wait, not nice.
Wait, that's a tank.
That's a tank, Ana.
Ana, please.
I'm keeping you up.
You keep me up.
I keep you up.
You keep me up, Ana.
This is... Please!
Ana!
Please!
I'm doing my... Oh my god, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
That's good.
Don't worry.
You won't regret this.
You won't regret this, Ana.
Trust me.
You will not regret this.
You will not regret this, I told you!
You won't regret this!
Bro, he beat it.
Yeah, just... I told you!
No regret!
Your Lucia won't heal you.
I will know!
I know that Lucia won't help you.
Your Lucia won't help you.
I know.
Your Lucia will still not help you.
Your Lucia will still not help you!
I know!
I knew it!
I knew he wasn't gonna help!
That's right!
That's... Who's a DP?
Yes, now!
What's that?
Wait... It worked, did it not?
I mean, I clearly carried that fight!
It worked!
Now I can get full ability power!
More... 7k damage...
I should really get more weapon damage though.
I... I feel like maybe I should have went for weapon power!
Oops!
I'm gonna quick get rid of Nanocola and then...
Ugh, if I sell Nanocola, I can get more weapon power.
You know what?
Yeah.
I'll do 15.
I'll sell Nan...
Oh wait, no.
I need multi-tool.
Whoops.
Where was multi-tool?
Multi-tool and then I'll sell...
I'll sell Nanocola so I can get 15%...
Attack... Whoa!
Yeah, 15% weapon power.
And sell the... Oh, I can't.
Alright.
Yeah, I was doing a lot of... A lot of suck.
There you go.
It's the match point.
If they keep it together, they can win this.
Yeah!
Three, two, one!
Our tank is not doing as well.
I knew that Lucio was not healing.
That's why...
That's why I was like...
That's why I went hard focused.
I hard focused everybody else.
I could tell... I could tell that Lucio was not doing anything...
For the team.
And that's good.
Whoa!
Nice.
Let's go.
Hello.
Hello, everybody.
Don't worry, I'm...
Okay, Orisa!
Okay.
That's like unfortunate.
Look at that.
See, I can.
I healed.
Look at that, guys.
Don't say I never healed, guys.
Don't...
Don't say...
I am your new tank!
I am your tank!
I...
I am your tank now!
Don't worry, I got you, Ana.
I'll tank for us.
Don't worry.
To take the healer.
And...
I don't...
I had my ult.
I...
That's crazy.
I already got my ult!
Great boss, Toki!
Yeah, I think Mora's fun in this elo.
I...
Toki is the team!
I need to see this again!
The tank that stepped up!
Alright, our soldier was good.
He has aim.
I wonder what his...
What his perks were.
Oh my god!
The...
Bionic...
That bomb with the...
The bomb with the right click is actually scary.
Alright, let's do one more Mora.
I think I...
That...
The right click bomb...
Yeah, that...
That rocket bomb was...
That build seemed very strong.
Yeah, I saw...
Boom, boom.
And then the person died.
It's fun when I get to be a raid boss.
I'll say it.
The raid boss build was really fun.
Also, I'm gonna get more water.
I'll be right back.
Also, if you guys wanna...
Check out Stadium yourself!
In Overwatch.
And also you can...
Click on the...
My...
The pinned...
Sorry.
English.
Um...
Click on the link pinned in my chat as well.
And you can try out Stadium as well.
You can click on the link.
I mean, Stadium is fun.
I like...
Experimenting with the builds.
I think...
I think the build experimentation was a good thing they did.
Cause it's like different things you can do.
And I guess like the longer the rounds are, the more you can like mess around with.
Which is the fun part.
Moro is fun in this elo.
It definitely...
I would say...
I think...
This is crazy.
This one is crazy.
The multi-ball...
The multi-ball is like...
Unfair.
Like...
That...
That's scary.
Now I...
Yeah.
In this elo?
Moro...
I can tell why Moro is good in this elo.
In the lower elos.
Just cause of the balls itself.
Yeah.
It's very busted.
The balls.
The power...
Uh...
Ethereal...
Ethereal one?
Okay.
Let's check.
Alright.
What can we do?
Power...
Is zero.
What is that?
This one?
Gain...
30%.
Oh, I have to aim.
And restore is 100%.
So instead of...
Cross...
Instead of cross...
We could try this.
We could try this for more like...
Weapon power.
I have to aim at...
I actually have to aim at the head though.
Okay.
So...
This is...
I actually have to aim at the head.
But like...
Am I willing to aim at the head?
Am I...
I have to aim at the head for that.
Aiming...
Exactly.
Aiming with Moro?
I was doing another Moro around.
I had too much fun with...
Being...
I had too much fun with that.
But don't worry.
Maybe this team will make sure I don't have fun anymore.
It could happen.
This team could make me regret having fun.
This team...
We could...
This team could be like...
You're starting to have fun?
Let me...
Stop that.
Alright.
Let's see how it goes.
Play whatever your heart's desire, buddy.
We're in rookie elo.
Like...
I don't know about you.
Yeah...
It's cause our Ana didn't have to...
Deal...
With...
The bullshit...
I went through...
Where...
Uh...
Where I was dived...
24-7.
Aw, they have Reaper though.
Aw, no.
They have their own Mora.
Okay, we know what to do.
We do multiball.
And then we do ability power...
Weapon power...
And...
Do we...
We do lifesteal, right?
I do lifesteal over attack speed.
Should I do lifesteal over attack speed?
Or...
Oh, we should do...
Actually...
Everyone could use a little help in the stadium.
Ability lifesteal or weapon lifesteal?
Which is better?
Weapon lifesteal or ability lifesteal chat?
Weapon lifesteal?
Okay, we'll do weapon lifesteal.
But like...
I'm thinking because...
I have three balls though.
I get three...
Uh...
Okay.
Alright, I'll do weapon for now.
I'll do weapon.
Cause I was thinking...
I get three balls though.
If I have multiball.
I'm always damaging.
Okay, we'll do ability lifesteal next.
Alright.
I got this.
Alright, let's see if I can still have fun.
With Mora.
We'll see.
We'll see if I can still have fun.
Or if...
If they shut me down.
Alright.
Three balls?
It's probably three balls.
Alright, here we go.
The ladies love it.
Ladies in chat.
Three balls or no?
Three.
Two.
One.
Capture the objective.
The map.
Oh, this person didn't build.
They tried to...
What?!
They left?!
How could you leave?!
This was my reinforce moment!
I can't believe it.
I can't believe they left.
I'm sad.
They left for my raid boss moment.
I told you.
They...
They still found a way to make me not have fun.
That's sad.
Wait, does the game keep going?
Wait, does it still go?
If somebody leaves?
Wait, that's not fair.
I can break them!
Oh!
Oh, the game keeps going.
Oh, that sucks for them.
Waiting for player?
Wait, do...
Can they get backfilled?
I know.
That's messed up.
Why?
Did they even get a penalty for it?
Wait.
Silly reaper.
You think I'm gonna heal our cast?
I will.
After I kill you.
I...
Oh, you think?
That's right.
I'm coming over.
I'm coming over, Juno!
I...
Oh!
That's a whole team.
That's right.
I'm coming over!
Give me my ult!
That's right!
I'll only kill you!
There we go.
Nice.
There, I healed.
Don't say I never healed, guys.
I healed one time.
Hello, Juno.
Oh, no.
I didn't even get...
I didn't get the heals.
Don't worry.
I have lifesteal for this one moment.
Yay!
The power is going to my head.
I almost walked too close to the sun.
Last, time to face off in control.
No!
This is too easy!
I want to have my moment!
Is there a surrender or anything?
Because it's just sad.
Damn.
Alright.
What was...
Guys, I forgot my build.
Guys, I forgot what we did.
It's...
Oh, wait.
We could do...
20%.
And then...
We focus on...
5% attack power.
10% weapon power.
And max...
Okay, we get that.
And then...
Oh, multi-tool.
Nano.
Okay.
What's multi-tool again?
Oh, the reduction.
Okay, let's get...
Oh, we don't have enough.
Okay.
We don't have enough.
So we'll do this.
So I can have weapon power.
And then we'll do multi-tool next.
I forgot what...
No, I have lifesteal right now.
So I don't need it yet.
I mean, it's a...
It's a 5v6.
So...
Oh, it's a 5v4.
Oh, wait.
It's a...
5v3.
Um...
So...
I guess we don't need a...
Excel sheet.
Wait!
You can join!
Wait, what?
You can?
Oh!
Oh, they left.
Oh.
I was gonna say!
Oh, you can come back!
Oh, it was a rejoin.
Bro doesn't understand this is comp.
Oh.
Aww.
And that...
Please, can I farm you for...
I need to farm you for stats.
Let me farm you for stats.
I need...
I need more stat equals more...
More LP or SR or...
Please, I need the stat.
Guys, I need to farm you for stat.
I don't care.
I'm not gonna play nice.
I need more numbers.
Hahaha!
I need a stat farm!
Give me stat farm!
Leave!
Leave or I stat farm you!
Yay!
Look at that, see?
I got plus 175 from stat farming.
Look at that!
Hahaha!
Yippee!
Stat farm!
Hahaha!
No, that wasn't the last one.
Cause I barely gotta...
Gotta do my builds.
Okay, let me look up.
I'm gonna Google.
Mora...
Best Mora build.
Stadium.
Google will be my answer.
Alright.
Okay, cross or...
Okay, obviously we gotta do the...
Okay, got the multi-ball.
And then the ethereal.
And then...
Okay, this is terrible.
No, I'm not.
Who is this?
In the Mora main subreddit.
I do not like this build.
I...
Hahaha!
Alright.
Okay, but where do you...
I need the...
I need like the chart, you know?
The...
You know, like the MOBA chart, you know?
Um...
Build stadium...
Guide.
There we go.
I need the chart.
I don't need like...
The end goal.
I need to know...
What...
Where it goes.
Hahaha!
Yeah, I...
I don't...
I don't know...
I need to know where to start.
And then like...
Where I go after.
I...
I can't...
I can't deal with end goal.
I need my upgrade chart.
Exactly.
Okay.
Unkillable Mora stadium build.
Alright.
Let me watch this video.
Hahaha!
What is this?
Okay.
Move speed...
Wait.
Was what I'm doing not good?
I feel so powerful!
I...
Hahaha!
I feel so strong!
Okay.
They're trying to be like...
Use ethereal accession first.
Then heartbeat sensor.
Then frenzy amplifier.
That doesn't sound right.
That...
Wait.
You mean my build was bad?
No!
Hahaha!
That means...
My build was bad?
No way!
Hahaha!
Oh, it's a survivability build.
Okay.
I won...
Strong build.
Bad build.
Yes, guys.
I'm in rookie elo.
And you can win with anything.
You...
Hahaha!
Wait.
I'm literally the tank DPS and support at the same time.
Usually the issue is that when you're playing support, you have no one to help you.
You can only enable your team so much.
But like now, I can do everything.
Hahaha!
I can actually do something.
Alright.
Okay.
Do I...
I don't want survivability.
I want...
Damage!
Hahaha!
The most broken...
Alright, ML7!
Tell me what to do!
Hahaha!
Alright!
Where is your guide?
Oh my god!
Do you not write down your guide?
Oh my...
I have to...
Okay.
I have to watch this video guys.
To figure out what his build is.
I...
Hahaha!
How do you progress it?
You can't just give me all purples right off the bat!
What?!
How do I progress this build?!
Hahaha!
Okay.
Um...
He gave me end gold build.
But like, I don't need that.
I need...
Start build.
Wait, I need those...
Yeah, I need the build sites.
That needs for maximum engagement.
Okay, what was it?
I did weapon power.
Weapon lifesteal.
And...
Ability power.
There we go.
Yeah, but like...
He gives me like...
He's...
He gives me end gold build.
I don't want...
What...
How do I start?!
Hahaha!
How...
How do I start?!
Okay.
Like, why is it purple?!
I don't have enough for purple!
The first round is almost...
Okay.
He shows me round three.
That's cool.
What about round...
One?
Hahaha!
Oh, here he goes!
Okay.
Nevermind.
I got it.
Okay.
He puts...
He puts armor?!
Alright.
I'm creating my own build.
I don't care.
I'm closing your video.
I'm L7.
Hahaha!
I'll watch it later.
And I'm turning on my ad block.
And I'm joking.
I'm joking.
That's a joke, guys.
That's a joke.
Hahaha!
I'm doing my own build.
I gave up.
A doki original.
I'm sorry, I'm L7.
I can't be bothered.
Hahaha!
I am!
Okay.
Wait, what?
How did he die so fast?
Oh my...
Oh my god!
Okay, the soldier was doing a lot.
Alright, that's not on me.
It was just...
Okay, okay, guys.
I might look at...
I'm gonna rewatch the ML7 video.
Hahaha!
Maybe he knows what's up.
Maybe...
Maybe he actually knows what's up, guys.
Hahaha!
No.
Heels?
What's that?
Okay, maybe I do need heals.
Maybe...
No, I don't.
Oh my god.
I can just heal with my orb.
Okay, I'm gonna start healing.
Hahaha!
Myself!
Oh.
I didn't think...
I didn't know where the staircase was.
I...
Hahaha!
Alright.
I...
Aw, I have to start...
Healing!
Mmm...
I guess...
Um, I'm doing my absolute best right now.
No!
I almost killed him!
Alright.
Let me...
Let me watch the video.
Okay.
Let me...
Let me watch the...
Maybe he's right.
Maybe he's right, guys.
Maybe the pro player knows what he's doing.
Alright.
I think the pro player knows what he's doing.
Let me look at what his builds are.
Okay.
Cyber Venom?
Can I afford that?
What the heck is Cyber Venom?
This one?
Okay, I need 10,000.
8, 9, 10.
Okay, what if I sell everything and get Cyber Venom?
Alright.
Alright, I believe.
Okay.
I sell everything and get Cyber Venom.
Surely, he knows what he's doing.
I believe.
I'm experimenting.
I'm stealing someone's build.
It's alright.
I'm stealing his build, I believe.
And then after that, I get Ethereal Exertion or whatever.
Make him!
Thank you for tier 1 sub!
Thank you, thank you!
Your build, our build.
And I'll make my own video.
And make it a little bit different.
I'll change round 1 and then keep round 2 and take his round 2.
Maybe it's my team.
It could be my team, you know?
Is it me?
No, it's my team.
This is the most I've had to heal my team.
I hate it.
I miss Raid Boss.
I miss my time when I was a Raid Boss.
Oh, you're right.
Reacting to ML7's build video.
You're so right.
You're the best to ever do it!
Alright.
Please.
I am doing my...
Oh my god, I actually...
Oh my...
Nothing can save you!
Nothing can actually save you!
Oh my god, I had 3 orbs!
3 orbs on...
On our Zarya!
How did that happen?
It was 3 orbs!
I don't understand.
Oh no, I can't do anything.
I'm trapped.
Guys, I think their Zarya is better than our Zarya.
Alright.
Alright, what do I do in round 3?
What do I do in round 3?
Okay.
Do I have enough?
Alright.
I do...
Aetherial Exertion here.
And then I have 6,000.
How can he afford all of this?
Alright, I'm doing my build.
I give up on his build.
I...
I've already given up.
Alright, I'll do Nanocoda.
And then...
And then I do...
Weapon power.
Okay.
Lifesteal.
Weapon power.
And then...
I do...
Ability power.
There we go.
Oh, multi-tool.
You're right.
Alright.
5%.
I need...
Let's see.
Let me get rid of...
Get rid of this so I can buy...
Oh, wait.
No.
I need 5,000.
God damn it.
I need multi-tool for the 5%.
Okay.
We'll do this.
Alright.
We'll use chat build.
I just think it's my team, honestly.
I...
My team's not it.
Alright.
Did I have...
Wait.
Did I do lifesteal already?
15% power.
I could do...
This one for it.
Oh, it's too late.
I did that.
And now I get weapon lifesteal.
And 5%.
That'll do that.
I got it.
Chat build will work, guys.
Oh, see?
It's not just me.
She...
She also...
It's not just me.
It said 3, 2, 1, and then she used it.
It's not just me, guys.
She also messed up.
I knew it was not just me, guys.
I knew it.
I knew it was not just me.
That doesn't understand.
I swear to god.
Zarya, please.
Zarya.
Zarya, what are you doing?
I'm going to let her die.
There's Zarya.
I don't know.
Zarya.
Oh man.
Zarya, please.
I'm playing my life.
I don't care about Zarya anymore.
I don't care.
If she dies, she dies.
If she dies, she just dies.
Oh man.
I think... I think our Zarya... doesn't know that... Yeah... I think for sure, their Zarya is 100% a better player.
For sure.
Like, it's not even, like... It's not even, like, a competition.
I think... I have a void!
Oh my god!
It's time.
Okay, one more.
That was a terrible game.
Our Zarya was... was a little special.
This guy's not rookie.
This guy is definitely not rookie, though.
What is a meta tank, anyway?
Chat.
What is a meta tank in... I'm curious.
What tank is meta in stadium, chat?
What's that?
What?
Is it Ryan?
Zarya?
Alright.
Let me look it up.
Best... Zarya... build...
What is it?
Sorry.
Stadium...
Alright.
Where do we go, though?
How do we...
Where is the...
Uh... Also, thank you for the raid!
Toddless and Kirisuna!
Thank you!
Hello, everybody!
My name is Doki!
Today, we're doing a sponsor for Overwatch 2!
Checking out stadium!
I actually stream on...
Uh... YouTube, but today I am on...
Uh... Twitch for my sponsors.
So, thank you, everybody!
Please check me out on YouTube if you want...
To see more of my content!
Alright!
Build time!
We gotta figure out this build!
Oh, yeah.
I like Shanghai Dragons for...
Uh...
For my Zarya skin.
Because it reminds me of Gigeru.
Uh...
Like...
That's why I have Shanghai Dragons.
The first, uh...
Overwatch female pro player.
In Overwatch League.
And she had, like...
Really, really good Zarya.
And D.Va, too.
Yeah, Gigeru.
Is Junker Queen good?
I see so many people on Junker Queen.
That's why I have Shanghai Dragons as my skin.
Yeah, people thought she was cheating.
And then I remember players were like...
I will quit pro play if she's actually a real player.
And then, like...
I don't know if they actually quit.
Alright, guys.
What?
What do we do?
Is it ability power?
Weapon power?
What do I focus on?
Uh...
What do I do?
Major...
Uh...
Weapon power?
Alright, weapon power.
Uh...
Okay, weapon power.
Do I have more weapon power or no?
Do I do...
I'll do lifesteal, too, for it.
Alright, what about power?
What do I do for the power, then?
Uh...
From...
Do not take notes from me because I don't know what I'm doing.
I...
Guys!
I have no idea what I am doing right now.
Guys, what is the power?
Power!
I'm literally...
Using chat build!
Alright.
Guys!
Power!
Vortex?
No limits.
Where the heck is vortex?
This one?
Cast...
Expires a slowing vortex that deals a hundred damage every two seconds.
Uh...
This one?
Or do...
Is there another one I should try?
Uh...
Yeah?
Okay.
Alright.
Let's do it.
Uh...
Reedy!
Thank you for gifting a sub to both Kirsuna and Dotless!
Thank you!
Thank you for tier one sub!
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's do it.
I don't even remember...
I don't...
It's been a while since I played Zarya.
Alright.
I do that because it's faster.
Here.
Oh, I should have saved that actually.
That's my bad.
I should have saved that.
Ooh.
Hello.
Please!
Hit my shield!
I have zero damage!
Genji get damage!
Why is no one shooting at my Genji?
Someone shoot my Genji!
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
That's what I wanted.
Okay.
Someone shot at my Genji.
Thank God.
Or shot at me.
Shoot me!
Alright.
Don't worry.
I tank.
Shoot me!
There you go.
I need that.
Please, keep shooting!
Yes!
That's what I needed!
Nice.
Okay, nice.
There you go.
Wait, where you go?
Alright.
Thank God I got shot at.
Shoot me!
I'm right here!
Yes!
I might have died doing that though.
I actually, I might have thrown doing that.
No.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I might have just stood there trying to wait for him to shoot me.
That's okay.
I get it.
It was worth it.
It's fine.
We were gonna die regardless.
We had ults.
Okay?
I hate baiting for them to actually shoot me.
It's actually so frustrating.
There we go.
I think that's like the worst part.
I need more damage!
That's it.
Angry.
There we go.
Oh my God!
That's a bomb!
We're- Oh my God!
We're- They grabbed- They bombed my grab!
Oh, they- Oh, that was unlucky.
I was not gonna live that.
That was- That was scary.
I don't think I was gonna live that, guys.
They- They did so much damage.
Wait, and they- They shot nothing?
Oh, I don't have shift.
Please.
Yay!
Huge often- Oh, what one person died?
Yeah, they see none.
What?!
Look at my damage!
I out-damaged my two DPS combined!
Alright.
What do we do here?
Huh...
So we- Do we focus on out- Do we focus on- We focus on weapon power, right?
I guess- Okay, multi- We'll do ice coolant, because- That's the cooldown reduction.
We need cooldown reduction for- For our bubbles, for sure.
And then- And then we do- Another round down, and it's safe to say- Let's see, do we- I don't think we- Okay, we can sell this and get- This lifesteal.
So then we can have- Weapon power and weapon lifesteal.
Yeah.
Alright.
That's fine.
I'm tanking.
That's all they need to know.
Alright.
You guys wanna see a coolant spray?
Oh, not that one.
This one isn't- Isn't- It's so beautiful!
Who wants to send a secure up tree with me?
Only if you're top 500- The- hahaha
No!
This is a top 500 exclusive spray.
You guys were wondering why I do this?
It makes you go faster.
It's like an old Zarya attack.
You travel faster if you do it.
That's good.
Nice.
I didn't see her over here.
But she's not shooting me.
What the heck?
Alright.
Oh my god, they just stopped shooting me!
I have to actually bubble my teammates now.
That's no fun!
I don't wanna bubble teammates.
Okay, yay!
My 10 damage!
Whoopee-doo!
No one wants to shoot me!
I don't understand!
Shoot me, please!
Oh, man.
Okay, that's fine.
No, I can't bubble her.
It's fine.
There you go.
I have to start bubbling my teammates now.
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
I can live a little longer.
No!
Everyone doesn't wanna shoot the bubble!
Okay, I'm sad.
When did they learn?
I wanna use it on myself, cuz I'm greedy!
Sigh!
Alright, Genji.
I guess I saved bubble for you.
I guess.
Genji, go in.
You're not gonna shoot me.
Go in.
There you go.
I mean, that's good.
Genji, go in, please.
Genji, go in.
I'm literally saving it for you.
There you go.
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god, that was a huge ult!
Yes!
Please do not die to bomb!
Are you serious, soldier?
You died to bomb!
Oh my god!
That was such a big ult, too!
And our soldier ran into the bomb!
There you go, I had to...
Oh, I got split, but that's okay.
As long as...
As long as I get healed, right?
That's okay.
That's...
Okay, I'm just saying, I am...
I'm just saying, I might be doing the most stuff for my team.
Meow, thank you for the hundred biddies!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, you can really tell!
Yeah, you can!
Yeah!
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, weapon power.
Okay, we gotta do...
Okay, we should be able to afford...
Stronger weapon power now.
50... 20%...
10% crit damage.
Okay, 13,000.
If I sell...
13,000...
11, 12.
Okay, I need to sell one of these.
Sell lifesteal so I can get...
This.
I can get 20% weapon power.
And then I can buy lifesteal here.
And then...
What do we get here?
For power?
What should we get in chat?
Oh, I can do this!
Is the fishing field good?
Or should I get better?
Something better?
It's a fierce competition...
Which one's better, guys?
And who...
Piercing beam?
Low...
No limits?
Pre-workout?
Particle accelerator?
Major flex?
Barrier benefits?
Or fishing field?
Follow your...
Guys!
You know my brain can't follow my heart!
My brain has nothing inside and my heart has...
Nothing as well.
I'm dead inside.
I...
Guys!
Please!
Not long now until the team's...
I don't know what...
Oh, I'm doing pre-workout.
I'm doing pre-workout.
I...
I'll do lifesteal.
I'm just a shell.
Alright.
Commencing attack on objective B.
I'm so fast with this.
Guys!
Everybody else can, like, have mobility.
And I just...
Fucking have to do this and hurt myself.
Haha!
The objective comes live in ten!
That's good.
Oh my god.
I used both bubbles there and they...
None of them took...
And he faded.
He faded.
I'm so sad.
There he is.
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
Please.
I gotta use it on myself.
Jesus Christ.
No!
The f... No!
The Nate does...
What?
The Nate can do, like, extra damage?
Okay.
I'm sad.
I tracked that Genji so well.
It does, like, after damage there.
The objective's online.
I swear.
I... Mora?
Nice, okay.
Oh my god, I...
My team's dead, so I don't know.
I lived for so long.
My team's dead, I don't know what to do.
I... I...
They have poison names?
Oh my god.
I did the best I could for my team.
Which is not...
Which is a lot, honestly.
Honestly, it was a lot.
Now that I think about it...
Why are you not peeking?
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Where...
Where is this...
Coming from?
Jesus.
Okay.
No, do not peek.
Now we peek.
Are you...
Oh my...
Jesus Christ.
I'll do everything.
I'll do everything if I need to.
Just heal me.
Please.
That's all I ask for.
I...
I need heals.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Look at the...
Look at the gap.
Look at the money gap.
Between my teams.
I can't.
The money gap between my teams is too crazy.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Weapon power.
15% weapon power.
We'll do...
Okay.
25% armor.
10% weapon power.
Consumes 20% up to...
For your current...
Okay.
Which one do we get for epic?
Uh...
10% attack speed.
Weapon power.
Get armor and attack speed.
We get...
25%...
25% armor and 10% weapon power.
We've already seen so much action.
And there's still more to come.
Alright.
We'll do that.
And then we can...
And then we should have more weapon power.
We're like just...
Just a tank.
Yes.
We're just so tanky right now.
Jesus.
I am literally out playing their...
I'm out playing their team.
So hard.
I'm sad.
Soldier and Genji.
Please.
I will...
Eventually double your points.
Please.
Genji and Soldier.
That's all I ask.
Alright.
Here you go.
And you guys are so fast.
Look at how slow I am.
I'm just a little Zarya.
Look how slow I am.
Please.
What do you want me to do?
Okay.
That's...
I have to use double there.
That's the only way.
Please.
Please peek me so I can give you...
I blocked him.
Okay.
Nice.
There you go.
Push the cart!
Alright.
There you go.
I predicted they were gonna shoot me there.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Please hit me.
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh.
How much more do I have to do?
Nice.
I needed that fire too.
Okay.
100.
Oh no.
Please.
No.
I gotta get that lifesteal.
Damage!
100%.
Jesus.
Yeah, you better be sorry.
You better be god damn sorry.
Oh my god.
I thought he would hit me.
But I guess not.
I should have known he was gonna shoot at my soldier.
How they were playing.
Okay.
They learned to stop hitting me.
You're dying.
You're gonna die.
I don't care.
I still... because I'm not getting healed.
I...
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, let's get rid of this.
And then grab more power, I guess.
Let's see, 25%.
Alright, let's get rid of attack speed so I can buy this.
And then, alright, power.
What do we... okay, what do we get?
Above... will pierce enemies.
Maximum energy increase to 150.
Oh, I'm never getting 150.
Ability purple third row high.
Get fantastic.
What?
Did you know that?
Alright, what do we get?
We have...
What do we get, guys?
Major flex?
What do we do?
Barrett benefits.
Fish and field.
Guys, we gotta figure this out!
Major flex?
Which one is?
Is this one?
Alright.
Now I know why.
How do they have more money?
They have more money than me!
Because their team's actually doing more as a team.
And I'm nearly the raid boss that they have to kill.
I'm...
I'm the raid boss they have to kill as a team.
They have more money than me though.
Somehow.
Now.
Where are they?
Where are they playing?
Jesus, they're so fast.
They're actually so...
They're so fast!
Oh my...
Everybody is so fast!
What is going on?
I won?
I don't...
Why is he...
Why is everyone so fast?
What is that?
Jesus!
I guess I'll kill him!
I...
I don't know.
Everyone...
I don't know what's going on.
I...
Okay.
I'll move up, I guess.
There we go.
Oh my god.
That was the clone.
Okay, we won.
Oh no.
Please, I only have 35!
That's right.
I don't care about you.
Please, I need more energy, please!
There we go.
I will kill you.
Oh my god!
Alright, now I know why Zarya is broken.
I...
Man!
Now you can't kill the raid boss!
Oh, that's me!
What are the 20 different things I did in this game?
Like...
Oh yeah!
This one!
While Zarya eats her ass!
Just get good, I guess.
Oh no!
Oh!
I can't...
I can't talk to people.
Cause sometimes I'm worried I get too toxic.
I...
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
Yeah, I have to make sure I...
Toxicity removed!
Alright, I think that's what you're getting the end on.
Unless you're like, great, now!
That's why I turned my socials off, guys!
I turned...
I made sure I don't talk to people!
Stay away from chat!
It was like...
Chat channel is disabled!
Whoops!
You're...
Good job, Pastoki!
Good job for saving yourself!
Oh man!
That was fun!
I had...
Uh...
I had a lot of fun!
Pastoki knew this time will come when Pastoki went a little too toxic!
I will say, Sadio was definitely incredibly fun!
Um...
But yes!
Huge shout out to...
Um...
Overwatch and Blizzard for sponsoring me today!
For me to check out...
Um...
Check out all the new updates!
Check out the new heroes!
The new skins!
Stadium in general!
Doing all the random builds and everything!
Uh...
It was definitely a great time!
Um...
Please do check out my link!
Click on the link!
Uh...
And pin in chat!
And...
Uh...
With the command!
Exclamation point Overwatch!
I had a great time!
Um...
Checking out everything!
As someone who hasn't played Overwatch in a while!
Going back in it!
I...
I now understand why Stadium is more fun right now!
Versus like what...
What there is at the moment!
Um...
Versus like regular rank!
Uh...
I would say Stadium...
For me personally!
It's definitely more fun than regular rank at the moment!
Only because it's a lot more fast paced!
And like...
Um...
I don't feel like I'm held hostage!
You know?
Like...
You know like when your team is...
Um...
When your team is losing!
And then you're like...
You don't know what to do!
And you're like...
Well this is obviously losable!
But like with Stadium!
It...
The games go by so fast too!
And...
Um...
Obviously make better builds!
And everything!
And then like...
The games go by really really fast!
So like that's where...
I mean I played five...
What?
How many hours did I play of Stadium?
Oh my god!
I went overtime!
For sure!
How long was I streaming for?
I streamed five hours!
I did four hours of Overwatch today!
Um...
And I think it was like three hours of just purely Stadium!
And...
Because I...
I actually enjoyed it a lot!
So yeah!
Uh...
Definitely thank you again!
To Overwatch for...
Um...
Sponsoring me!
And being able to show how fun it is!
The different builds you can do!
There's like so many different wild builds you can have!
Um...
The Zarya one was definitely...
I now know...
I know why Zarya is OP!
I...
I can tell why Zarya was incredibly OP there!
Literally I was just walking forward!
And...
And like I didn't even need my healers anymore!
Before...
I just went lifesteal!
And I just walked up!
I was like...
I don't need you anymore!
I have lifesteal now!
I...
It's...
I was like...
I don't need to cry about heals!
All I have to do is do damage!
I...
I became the raid boss!
I am...
You can heal yourself!
Who cares about you?
Um...
But yes!
For those who are new here...
My name is Doki Bird!
I usually stream on YouTube!
So please check me out on YouTube!
Do exclamation point YouTube!
Um...
And um...
You guys wanna know whenever I'm live on Twitch!
I do...
Tweet out whenever I'm live!
So do exclamation point social!
Follow me on Twitter as well!
And if you wanna support me via other memes!
I do have Doki merch!
And also Gamersupps!
Uh...
You use my code on Gamersupps!
You get 10% off on all your orders!
Um...
I guess that's everything to show!
You can buy my voice packs!
There's no merch right now!
There's only voice packs!
Um...
But yeah!
Just check me out on all my other different platforms!
Uh...
Thank you again to Overwatch for the sponsor!
I had a great time!
And...
Please check out Stadium!
And check out the new season!
Um...
Definitely!
Uh...
They did a lot of updates this season!
So I can see why a lot of different things are now different or more different!
And there's the perk system and everything!
A new hero!
The stadium feature!
Uh...
And...
Thank you all for the subs!
The betties!
The follows everyone!
As always everybody!
Stay hydrated!
Posh check!
Get up and move around to get that bluff line!
And if you stay up for me!
Head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
Thank you everybody for watching!
Uh... Tomorrow there's gonna be no stream!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!